right
good afternoon everybody i will bang my
virtual gavel
and welcome you to the virtual meeting
of planning committee b
my name is councillor andy crump and i'm
chairman
for this meeting members you have been
provided with council's etiquette for
virtual meetings in advance of this
meeting
however i need to reiterate the main
points
one please ensure your device is fully
charged
or is charging two please
mute microphones while not speaking
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak
when invited to address the committee
please ensure your microphone is
switched on
and switch off immediately once you've
finished
please ensure you have switched off or
to silence
any other devices you have that may
interrupt the proceedings
if any members encounters i.t problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting
they should use best endeavors to rejoin
as quickly as possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting
they will be deemed to have left the
meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue provided
it reminds
there is something in the chat box which
details members
committee services uh phone numbers
contacts
please note that meeting is being
broadcast live
and that members of the public are able
to view the proceedings
i can confirm that checks have been made
to ensure that all members of the
committee
are in attendance and i've confirmed in
presence of the council's legal officer
that they can see and hear the
proceedings
also presidents online with me are
offices from
democratic services legal and planning
public speakers will be given a
30-second warning during their speaking
time
once you are finished speaking the
committee may wish you to
ask questions so please remain in the
meeting
if there are no questions you can leave
the meeting and continue to watch the
pre
proceedings via the live broadcast
when planning committee members vote
could they please ensure that they
identify themselves
and speak to the microphone so that
their vote is
understood clearly both by other members
of the committee
and also those watching the webcast
members should respond for against
or abstain
we will now move on to a gender item
one which is apologies for absence
sorry a chairman i can't apologize from
councillor rock
and we have councillor harvey has joined
planning committee b
right thank you for that to this uh just
like to say a few words
uh send our best wishes to cancer the
rock
i wish him a full and speedy recovery
and i'm sure members will join me in uh
wishing them
wishing and well so uh happy for you to
apprec agree that
and secondly welcome aboard councillor
harvey to the good ship planning
committee b
i'm sure we will value your rowing of
this boat
equally as other members of committee so
welcome aboard
and don't forget your rowing oars thank
you
thank you mr chairman all right
agenda item two disclosures of interest
um right this one
uh i would like to declare just
declare or disclose that i've had an
email
from mr fletcher on item number four
which relates to the application that
for green acres milan newborn onstar
and i've also had an email from
councillor fleming on item 5
which relates to broome junction former
railway station high street broome
and again i noted those but i will be
coming to the mata
to the meeting and those applications in
particular with an open mind
so no predeterminations um
can i confirm kenza hancher serafin
yes i've also had the the same email
have you
you've had from mr fletcher and mr
fleming can we all take that
we've all had that one have we yeah
councillor kettle you indicated that you
want to
declare uh disclosure of interest as
well
uh yes thank you mr chairman uh in
carrying out my
uh science prior to the meeting um i
attended the
psychic room hill coincidentally at the
same time as mr councillor fielding
um the applicant was on site
um and in fact in doing so with enable
us to get on the site
who looked round um but
i can confirm that uh uh
having been there i'm coming to this
meeting with an open mind
why don't you catch the kettle catch the
fielding
i i was on site um and
talked to the ward member and also the
applicant
um but i'm open-minded as to
to the proceedings thank you councillor
fleming
obviously as i'm supporting uh the item
for broome junction
um i obviously have to declare that i
won't be able to take part in the actual
meeting and voting for that particular
thing so um from that perspective um
just registering the fact that i have an
interest and that i am supporting the
the application and you're you've
registered to speak and you're i have
ready to speak yeah
so you know i'll bring you in as as the
ward member on that council
catch the harvey i'm in a similar
position to councillor fleming
i'm speaking in relation to item number
four
i'll take no part in the debate or the
vote
thank you very much um sorry one more mr
chairman i
there is an application in my ward uh
where i am registered to speak
uh that is application seven
um
making for that and will be speaking
so that's great i think it's always best
to
get the decline declarations out early
avoid any confusion and then we're all
out and aboveboard so thank you for that
let's take a little while but i think
it's worth spending the time
we will know once i've got on my pieces
of paper
uh move on to the gender item number
three which is the
the minutes uh i'm looking for a
proposal
and a second for the minutes of the
meeting held on the first of july
2020
uh catch the mills yes um
i have to propose to accept these uh
minutes mr chairman
thank you cancer mills and cancer cattle
did i see you on your cat you're happy
to second
i'm happy the second yeah
and this will be doing a roll corner of
this for those minutes
yup thank you chairman councillor crump
for councillor mills
council meals for councillor fielding
councillor fielding are you there i am
muted
uh i for some reason it did switch
itself off i am
four thank you councillor fleming
catcher fleming for councillor harvey
councillor harvey four councillor
henshaw seraphin council henshaw serif
in four
and councillor kettle how's the cattle
fall
that's unanimous chairman thank you
chairman may i make a comment before we
proceed i just completely lost
the i was knocked out of teams and had
come back in again i don't know whether
there is something wrong with the system
uh thanks for that cancer
building yeah if you do get out if you
can try and get back in as soon as
possible
um and if you have problems with uh
having problems with this contact
democratic services
and those who will get back in as soon
as possible i know that
this is the problem with virtual team
meetings um
the broadband just go down so we'll
we'll try and bear with you if you can
bear with us as well i'm sorry to say
i'm back in the meeting
right thank you very much right we'll
now move on to agenda item 4
which is application i'll just check
this make sure
nineteen slash zero two
six nine six ful green acres mill lane
newborn on star
demolition of existing an erection of
five number
two story detached earnings and i invite
playing officer joseph brooke
to present the application thanks chair
let me just share the screen
can everybody see that
we've got the one where it's the um can
you see us
see the map now yeah thank you thank you
joe that's right
thank uh the site is located on the
southern edge of new building permission
to
demolish the existing dwelling green
acres so i'll see as a site location
plan with green acres
as it is and construct five new drains
from the application site as indicated
by the red line boundary
so also the garden area two green acres
the whole site will be developed for
five dwellings
two of the dwelling houses will be
sighted directly fronting onto mill lane
so this is mill lane here that's plots
one and two
which we directly sitting on to it and
the third three dwellings will be
located to the rear
which is currently the garden space of
green acres so obviously plots three
four and five
to the rear of green acres at the minute
the proposed dwellings are all set at
two stories high with detached garages
uh either side for plots one two and
three so you can see the attached
garages
there all for the front protection for
plots three and four
so tax carriages just there
plots one three and four plays an
architectural detailing with large-scale
apertures
timber boarding with modest fenestration
for windows and wooden doors
whilst plot two is proposing a two-story
design with simple fenestration
detailing as indicated in the officers
report
this is a front section taken plan taken
from mill lane so this is plots one and
two
this is orcad drive as existing this is
the third which was granted planning
permission very recently
and is presently under construction
this is the east side sections of the
site so you can see the existing drain
orchard drive this should be plot two
and that's plot floor so it gives you a
good indication of
dwelling heights from rich heights in
respect to the application
this is the other side of the west side
section so that's plot one so
the orca drive sort of standing out
there's the
recent approval uh on the first
there's plot three and plot five once
again gives you a good
line of sight of the ridge heights
this is a photo taken of green acres as
it is at the minute as you see it's one
story bunga with two story elements
about one and a half story elements
pauses
this is taken along if the powerpoint
would
this is taken along uh mill lane this is
facing down south along the way when you
come off stratford road
that's coming up to mill lane uh facing
stratford road up to the top
this is the rear where the site will be
so green acres there will obviously be
demolished and two plots one and two
would be cited
this is the neighboring property so
plots
would be cited here this is how the site
is
which would have the further plots four
or five
and that to be honest that's where plot
five would be
that's the end the presentation in
consideration the area's development
plan
national policy and guidance as well as
the relevant statutory consultations
the office of recommendations on
planning balance approval subject to
recommended conditions
i sat out in the officer's report as you
will see in the update sheet the african
has provided a detailed checklist in
response to the council's recently
adopted part 5
climate change and mitigation as part of
the development requirements spd and you
will also know further correspondence
with the ward member
council harvey and wcc the highways
as well as an additional technical
question from council kell
thank you chair thank you very much uh
joe just trying to come off up
catch the mills have you just indicated
chairman yes uh uh my apologies mr
chairman
um i've just noticed the applicant
um see gilbert and son
and he lives in my award um
i i feel i can't take any part in this
um
in this um debate on this uh application
mr chairman
so your son you you you know him
well and i know cliff well yes thank you
thank you
we're still we're still quiet i'll take
it yeah we should be
the core on it's been changed now i'm so
sorry mr chairman
i've just noticed that no no problem but
uh but it's
just said now then uh rich come out
later so
yeah well if you uh just turn off your
mic and and your camera for this one
cancer mills and uh withdraw from this
one
thank you i thought when you indicated
that something like that to speak so
right let's check anything else
and are we okay anybody else before we
go on to our first speaker
no good and our first speaker
is mr paul fletcher mr fletcher are you
with us
yeah i'm here can you hear me loudly
clear yes we can hear you mr fledger
thank you
uh you've got you've got three minutes
and we will give you a warning
with 30 seconds to go and please stay
with us after your presentation
in case there are any questions from the
committee for you
far away when you're ready please thank
you
so i'm not against development i i live
in a family home on middle lane
converted from a barn
on a wife's grandfather who was a
property developer we all need a place
to live
and we all have the right to develop our
land if we desire
development however must be appropriate
a word which is in frequent use
throughout the sec called strategy
documents i thank the members of the
committee for allowing me
the time to ask them to consider whether
the recommendation to accept this
development
truly is appropriate constructing five
dwellings supporting five families their
cars visitors and deliveries on a plot
to where today there's only one
can five new dwellings really be safely
constructed in this restricted space off
mill lane
and is it the right location to meet the
requirements of five busy families
and up to 15 additional cars which is
more than double the number there today
i consider it to be unsafe but i
consider it to be over development
might the committee members take into
account the following facts during the
decision making
the required visibility display at the
junction with mill lane and the a3400
cannot be achieved
looking towards ships and from mill lane
2.4 meters back to the main road
65 meters is the maximum distance at
which you can see the curb
i've measured it and i've stood there
and the highway authority reached the
same conclusion in 2015.
a pedestrian gate now exists in the
fence separating mill lane from the
kendrick's development at the top
there's no reference made on the green
acres plan to have foot traffic through
that gate
onto a modified mill lane will be
handled safely and the gate is not shown
on any green acres drawings
this has to be addressed the gate is a
recent addition by unknown parties and
is unplanned
however planning enforcement officer ron
goodyear has confirmed that the council
have no authority to request its removal
it is in increasingly regular use by
adults and children from 35 new houses
to access the stables
and mill lane itself due to the poor
positioning of the gates it's unfighted
from the lane
and the risk of an accident here with
increased traffic particularly during a
prolonged construction effort is
significant
on the lower unadopted section of middle
lane residents children and
grandchildren
play and ride bikes they roll more or
less unhindered between homes
crossing the lane to the allotments and
to play in the field
the risk of hgvs or plants being brought
down onto this part of the lane
is significant if the development is
improved and the impact of this
risk around small children would make
continuation of this freedom to play
outside
your own home impossible to allow safely
there's no room for maneuver once
on this section of the lane large
vehicles have to reverse unsightly back
up the lane crossing the farm track
blind
and in the past of damaged verges gates
walls
due to the narrowness of the lane at
that point no one on the lane is against
development the principle but
building a small estate where today a
single home stand in a restricted spot
is inappropriate and unsafe the lane
already has two active builds ongoing
with 36 new homes there and approval for
a third
site seems to me to be clear over
development i
thank the committee in advance for their
consideration and again for the
opportunity to voice my opposition to
this scheme
right thank you thank you mr fletcher
well within time
any questions for the objective for the
resin
no can i just pick on one then please mr
fletcher
certainly you mentioned about uh
36 homes being built in that line
uh and as part of your presentation you
were questioning
how safe it would be for heavy laura's
coming up and down the line
particularly the unadopted part of the
line where you were saying that
the children played almost unhindered
yeah yeah do these lorries excuse my
ignorance on this and i just want to
clarify for mine
um do those lorries actually go down
that part of the line to that other
development
no they don't they they shouldn't so the
kendrick's development
they they wouldn't they chose not to use
mill lane to access their development at
the top
because um they just thought it was
unsafe they weren't going to be able to
build 36 houses
and access them via mill range they
chose not to do that
they built actually a temporary exit
onto the a3400
and to allow them access and delayed the
completion of one of the houses until
the rest had been built
and they've now built a new house over
the top of that and over the top of that
yeah that entrance
oh yeah thanks to that yeah again i'll
just wanted to point the clarification
um cause the fielding
can you unmute john i am unmuted so
the um mill at the bottom there is that
um
uh a listed building and has that
have people the right to go and um visit
it and go around it or is it just
um what it is uh a home
i believe it just to be a private
residence i i don't believe it to be a
visitor attraction or or listed
brilliant thank you any any further
questions
right mr fletcher thank you very much um
thank you
free to go but feel free to stay and
watch the broadcast
thank you man thank you
right we have our next speaker or
speakers
which are jane cashmore and david neal
um jane and david are you are you with
us please
yes i'm here yes i'm here thank you
um will you be splitting the time
between you have you got and who's going
first
yeah so i'll be going first it's jane
cashmore here um i'll be taking
approximately the first minute and then
i'll pass on to dave neil from david
checker associates to take the remainder
of the time
thank you jane after you know the
process far away when you're ready
please
good evening councillors the officer
report before you is comprehensive and i
thought
i'd take the opportunity to reiterate
some of the key points before leaving
days to cover highways matters
the application was submitted following
pre-application inquiries with the
district council and warwickshire county
council
page 15 of your agenda sets out that the
principle of development is acceptable
the site lies within the physical
confines of newborn onstar the category
three local service village
and within the draft filter carrier
boundary in your emerging site
allocations plan
at page 17 your officer concludes the
design
layout and form are representative of
the number of nearby properties
would not dominate the neighbouring
dwellings safeguard the existing
building line
and would suitably blend in the existing
street scene
the proposal provided for in excess of
the council's minimum garden areas
and adequate separation between
dwellings and neighbours
our diversity offsetting is secured and
county ecology raised no objections
i'll now leave days to cover highways
impact
thank you jane good evening councillors
my name's dave neal and i work for the
david tucker associates i'm a local
specialist transport planning
consultancy by way of background i also
worked at warship county council for 15
years in the highway development
management team as a senior engineer
i'm aware concerns have been raised by
third parties and council behavior
regarding the ability of mill lane
to cater for any increases in traffic
generated by the proposed development
two passing baits will be provided on
the middle name which will widen usable
widths at least five meters and open two
cars to the past
silver also proposed to widen the middle
lane at the junction with the a3 400
structured road
to again ensure two vehicles can pass
reducing the potential for conflicts in
the main roads
with regards to achievable visibility
for the vehicle's external name
the junction is operated safely for a
number of years which shows a day-to-day
basis the existing visibility is
sufficient
but to ensure any intensification of the
junction wouldn't be detrimental to
highway safety
in 2019 the applicant commissioned a
speed survey to determine the existing
speed of chocolate
following the side that it's a measured
achievable visibility
it's completed 141 meters to the north
113 to the south
offset by meter from the turbine could
be achieved
standards that will be close to the
tuition road network since the a46
a5 m40 etc would require 160 meters
based on these reported speeds
and representations referring to 250
meters and not relevant to a 50 mile an
hour in non-strategic roads
guardians views on non-strategic routes
requires lesser resistances
due to the required parameters of
manufactures results in a minimum
stopping site distance of 109 meters
therefore an excess of this can be
achieved in both directions
finally the applicant will be provided
in short section but wait 30
seconds which rock curves facilitating
access to the existing footwear on the
southern side of the a3400
this will not only provide safe access
to future residents but also provide
betterment for existing residents and
middle lane
wcc fully consider the submitted details
no objections to the development
thanks for your time and we're happy to
answer any questions
all right everybody any questions to
the agent or the applicant please
um i will just i've been
asked the uh
the resident raised the question i don't
know whether
january picked up on it um about
the un made up part of the line
uh and the unsuitable
nature of the line i know you mentioned
um
mr neil mentioned two passing ways um
it's concerned about the the hgvs
etc um just give us a little bit more
detail about that please
yeah my understanding and dave um please
correct me if i'm wrong
is that the application site um accesses
out onto the
part of mill lane which is the public
highway so there shouldn't be
construction vehicles
um using the unmade parts of the
of mill lane dave would you agree with
that
yeah yes
brilliant super duper any further
questions
right thank you jane and thank you dave
um
thank you very much excuse me german
counselor kevin got a question oh
i didn't pick that up sorry cancer
kettle
thank you mr chairman um i just wanted
to
understand better the transport
consultants um
background and qualification he
mentioned he came from orange county
council
could you just give us a little bit more
on that i'm sorry i couldn't quite get
that
i did say i can't i made a note earlier
on i couldn't hear what he was saying
um easily i i did manage to catch most
of it
yeah certainly i i was at uh i worked at
washington county council in the
development management team so the same
team that would be responding to
any consultations um such as this um i
was in that ticking for 15 years
and left the team as the senior engineer
team leader
in 2014 before moving to davidson
associates
thank you yeah okay sorry about that
my chat thing wasn't working
particularly well so
um catch the field and i've got you down
as a question
or was that a question to the previous
speaker
that was that was to the previous
speaker but i i'm quite happy to ask a
question
because i was involved on the committee
for the kendrick site
and one of the big arguments and i
raised it myself
was the fact that kendricks would not
come out was not allowed to come out
onto mill lane and they had to do the
circuit through the neighboring
developed site um it was
um i complained
on that one because of the fact that um
um emergency vehicles dust uh dustbin
lorries
etc it was very tight and so
i can't see the difference that doing
the kendrick site with
and not being allowed to access onto
mill lane um
being too too narrow and too tight as
any
um compared to what we're talking about
today i believe that
again this is uh um whether um
mr neil was involved in those
discussions
i don't know so
uh just to sum up your question in
the the size of the line for
htv vehicles and also the fact that the
previous development was did not was not
allowed onto the
thing so therefore why was that
i don't think he can answer about the
previous development he cannot answer
the question about the size of the line
and its suitability for hd vehicles as
part of the construction
well i think that and also therefore
dustbin lorries
yeah hcv vehicles and that's it um
we finally got to a question there mr
neil are you able to answer that please
yeah certainly i i you know i wasn't
involved in the previous
uh previous scheme don't worry about
that yeah just just the current
yeah again the lane itself is
is adopted highway um it is suitable for
using refused vehicles what we've made
sure is that the
internal site layout can accommodate uh
refuge vehicles and enable them to turn
within the site um so they don't have to
reverse at any point
and obviously any construction related
vehicles um we'll also have to
enter the site the other turn uh during
the construction pace
um we're looking to implement some
passing day obviously that will be a
wider point to enable two cars to pass
the development's completely far too
they'll also be in attention when the
construction takes place
um and also the county council powers to
ensure that the developer
um rectifies any issues with the lane
during the construction phase
if indeed something was better
overrunning the verge etc uh but they
can go back to the developer nothing to
put that right
right thank you very much right
you're definitely free to go now uh jane
and dave thank you very much move on to
our next speaker which is councillor
harvey who's the ward member
councillor harvey so you've got five
minutes
if you could uh start when you're ready
please
thank you mr chairman i've set out uh
the planning reasons why i think that
this application conflicts
with the requirements of cx cs 9 15
and 16 in my written submissions the
case officer takes a different view
as he's entitled to do but at least this
illustrates an honest difference of
opinion based on different
subjective evaluations approval of this
application will lead to five houses
being built each with a requirement for
parking space
for three cars the traffic generated by
these houses will effectively
double the volume of traffic in mill
lane
all the traffic using mill lane has to
negotiate the junction
with the 83400 which is in a 60 miles an
hour permitted
area although i and many residents of
newbold may take the view
that the application should be refused
because the village has already taken
a higher proportion of new dwellings in
relation to cs16
than all but five settlements in the
entire district
this is a matter for judgment but there
is an objective and factual basis upon
which i suggest this application
should be refused the issue at stake is
the safety of the public
the national requirements for the length
of visibility displays
are set out in guidance notes they're
readily available
on highway authorities websites and had
i had it been within the rules
i would have been able to illustrate
this with a slide showing the title page
of the relevant document
issued last year for example by
hampshire
county council in the case of mill lane
and the a 3400 junction because the
junction lies in the 60 miles per
hour area the length of the splay line
required
is 215 meters the question of whether
the required space lines can be achieved
at this junction
was considered in relation to an
analogous application
at the exchange in mill lane in 2015
the highway authorities engineer at that
time who was required to be familiar
with the design manual for roads and
bridges was
clear in his assessment physically they
could not
and on behalf of the highway authority
he registered his objection
to that end interestingly
the applicant's transport statement in
this case
fails to draw the committee's attention
to this
objection the evidence now before you
demonstrates
that nothing has changed in the
intervening period
yet the highway authority has not
objected to this application
when the circumstances of the junction
suggests
it should have the transport statement
submitted in support
and upon the highway authority upon
which the highway authority now relies
convenient to its proposition has chosen
to use criteria appropriate to an urban
street rather than those of an a-class
road in a 60 miles per hour
area upon which its opinion is based
clearly
the highway authority has has come was
confident
that the that the objection it
registered in 2015
would have been sustained in the event
the result was that the application in
relation to the exchange
was withdrawn whatever the merits or
otherwise of this application
and i suggest there are other planning
grounds where there's room for different
interpretations
the evidence on splay lines and their
requirement for reasons of road safety
seems clear and unambiguous as the
highway authority stated in 2015
the requirements cannot physically be
met
in this instance members of the
committee there have have a choice
they can choose to turn a blind eye
ignore this evidence and conclude
in the greater scheme of things that the
guidance on splay lines
in a 60 mile per hour area is
interesting
but optional and malleable if this is
the case
such a decision may in the extreme
be cited at a future coroner's inquest
into the death
of someone as a result of an accident at
this junction
or they can conclude that the highway
authority's objection in
2015 was completely justified by the
facts
and their remains completely justified
by the facts
on this basis members of the committee
will have to decide whether such an
objection
in the interests of public road safety
is of sufficient weight
either on its own or taken together with
other reasons
to justify a decision to refuse this
application
my view and that of the residence of
medicine
is that this is the case and this
application should
justifiably be refused thank you mr
thank you councillor harvey any
questions to the ward member please
catch the kettle i can just see your
hand because i've got my chat up so
uh yep if you could unmute yourself and
come in
uh counselor harley you may have seen
the
update sheet um where
i asked um mr brook a
a question as we invite you to do a
technical question
um asking um him or highways officers to
reconcile
the very different viewpoints
expressed by the 2015 2015 officer which
you have
identified and commented on and the 2020
officer do you have any
um understanding given the amount of
time you've spent on
the highways issues can you throw any
light on the
conflict between the two bits of
highways advice
from the same authority
um i'm not a highways engineer and i
can't
give you a technical answer i don't have
that level of expertise
my role is as i see it as the ward
member is to sh
is to point out that a qualified
highways engineer from the warwickshire
county council assess that road
in relation to an application which was
almost exactly the same
it's only the position that's different
that application was for five
houses uh of four and five bedrooms with
which would have produced the similar
some number of of vehicles and movements
and the the the officer on that occasion
was
absolutely clear in his objection
physically because of the the the
alignment of the carriageway
and because of the position of the
hedges the
when you stand 2.4 meters back
you cannot achieve what he regarded on
the guidance
um published guidance that the
the display lines of 215 meters could
not be achieved now i don't think it's
for me
as as a mere ward member to arbitrate
between
that that engineer's view and another
engineer's view
all i'm here to do is to point out that
a qualified
highways engineer in relation to a
similar application
involving similar volumes of traffic
came to an absolutely
unambiguous conclusion that the
requirements
could not be met
thank you councillor harvey any further
questions
right i think we can move on
thank you council harvey
right uh we'll now move on to
uh questions points of clarifications
for the officer
any points of clarification for mr brook
catch the kettle
we can't hear you chris completed me too
i was typing question before i
am um mr brook
thank you for your very clear
comments earlier on um
this is a point i've raised in the past
but i'm still not comfortable
you comment that this is an
lsv2 i think uh i might have to say
uh unless there are two of us v3 sorry
sorry which would normally have
um an allocation um
of well a share of the 2000 houses
which for category three village would
be
um 59 and that the last five year
housing landscape
um calculation 12 months ago
58 had already been built with
a first further 41 commitments
in other words total of 99.
now that's well in excess of the
59 which were not
allocated but identified towards an lsv
3 village and when i look at uh
inspector peter to drew's comments in
his report
he says that um the numbers give an
indication of the quantum of development
appropriate for each category of lsv 18
to account sustainability
um and that number is appropriate that
gives local communities and developers a
degree of certainty
we've actually already met um the total
allocation towards lsv's um
um lsv's which was 2000
last year we actually got 2 400.
how do you reconcile the fact that we've
exceeded 2000 already
but this is uh this village or this
settlement has doubled
uh the number allocated is
maybe too strong a word but 99 versus 59
is quite a lot higher
and this will clearly be on top of that
um how do you reconcile that
those two statements and the inspectors
report
so thank you um there's there's
a few aspects to that to be honest uh
firstly we have to appreciate that
no policy and any local plan especially
that's come from government guidance for
the mppf
can halt development it is simply not
allowed to do it to be honest
so you can't just have an overarching
figure and then just say that's it we're
not having any more development ever
again
it's it's not allowed um the inspectors
decisions we've had a few of them
regarding them and most of them have
come down to conclusion that
if it's this is small scale developments
this is only five dwellings
if you can fit that within the criteria
of the lsv
and also within the built-up period
boundary which is part of the
spd which is our consultation minute
then the criteria can be met for that
hours and allocation so you have to kind
of do it on the assessment of
what is in that area how big of a
development is it and five dwellings is
a minimal development the site
itself provides ample room for garden
space and parking
and therefore in the whole context of
things and there has been various
decisions
from various inspectors highlights that
we couldn't refuse it on the case that
fire dwellings is therefore
such an over the criteria on the out on
the area
that warrants that the shops in that lot
wouldn't be able to support it
at the same time there's also an
argument that the more development you
put into an area
which is included within the babs
actually would then bring forward more
shops and facilities and bus transports
and all that
as well so you can't just say that's it
the housing criteria number is met
development stops because we can't have
any more development
you have to keep expanding putting them
in there in guidance with policy which
policy are obviously saying this is okay
it's being built a very boundary
so therefore then still provide the
services and facilities
even coming forward in the future i hope
that makes sense
uh thank you mr brooke i think that's
probably the clearest demonstration of
that issue that i've ever heard
presented so thank you
sorry andy you have microphones on you
thanks jack mr jeffrey um you indicated
you want to come in
david yes i think uh i think as
uh councillor kettles uh illustrated
uh joseph brooks um covered this topic
pretty well it really is just to
re-emphasize the point that the
um figures within the core strategy have
not been held by inspectors
to be a limit on development we have
lost appeals
on that ground before um it is something
which
officers would turn members away from
it's not sound
a sound planning approach um to consider
that those are
arbitrary limits on on development
within any
lsvs or groups of lsvs
um yeah i think that probably sums it up
thank you
i've got a question for mr chambers
uh ross can you hear me
can you hear me ross thank you yeah
uh just to reiterate the point of
question
my understanding is that
regarding an application that was five
years ago
um was almost exactly the same
application if i quote case the harvest
uh words um
how much weight does that
have compared to a current
view from the highways authority
well we're considering the application
before us not the one from five years
ago
the county council have been alerted to
the fact that they gave a different view
five years ago
and they've explained why um they don't
offer an objection
to this application um that's set out
fully in the update and we need to go
with their current advice on this
application rather than a past
application
thank you thank you ross any further
points of
clarification to the officer
no are we happy though that we go on to
to the debate who
wants to start on this one
yeah i can see you chris but uh i can't
yep
fought away um
well i take um
mr brooks um
comments uh with the seriousness they
deserve
um that we should not be limiting
um any development on the basis that we
have passed
um a fixed number um
this is a substantial increase
on a specific plot gone from one to five
um and i'm mindful that mr drew did say
that the numbers that he referred to
should um give communities and
developers a degree of certainty
um and this this settlement has
absorbed in sustainability terms
considerably more um than
[Music]
was envisaged in the core strategy and
whilst i
fully accept mr brook's comments and i i
understand where he's coming from where
do we draw the line about what is
acceptable um
additions on top of core strategy
numbers and where do we not
my view is on on that
5 on 50 or 6 or 10 on 50 or
maybe a little bit more than that might
be um
considered reasonable i think new build
on star
is actually received would have received
more houses practically well it will
have received more houses for
an lsv2 when it's lsv 3
and it's actually verging not far from
you know
when we put up we've got another number
of years before the core strategy ends
we could end up with it increases lsv
one
um in terms of the number allocated to
it so i have a real problem
with that despite um mr brooks
very clear uh and helpful comments
on top of that we then have mr heart of
councillor harvey's
comment um and the app the applicant's
travel uh also highways expert
was actually part of the team
um who in 2015 um
rejected this site as being unsuitable
for a five house development
on a one site um
[Music]
of what a former plot so um
to have the answer is we don't know what
the previous
cat what previous um advisor
or highways expert at warwick's council
why he came to that opinion
i'm sorry in in a way
i think we should defer this kind of
this application
because to say that because a former
highways expert has left
his his opinion no longer counts for any
weight at all
um doesn't bode well for the future if
every time
a highways guy leaves county council
says well he's gone there for his
opinion isn't valued
um mr harvey has made out some very
clear points in his presentation um
as he did in his uh original submission
to the application
uh as to why warwick county council find
this
unsuitable site and mr fielding on
council fielding
uh likewise i sat on the previous
um applications for over the road where
some of these things were reviewed i
can't just
ignore what has been said five years ago
it's the same road
coming out onto the same road and
everywhere else in the county we get
highways saying
yo you know visibility splays got to be
this that's the rule book
and if you can't beat those plays um you
can't develop
and suddenly on this one we got a
complete about phase from
previous county council advice so i
think
we either defer and
request the county council not to not to
effectively rubbish a previous officer's
opinion
but for the county council to re-look at
these items
and reckon genuinely reconcile
the two alternative viewpoints
you don't want to do that in which case
um if you're not
if you're not happy with that mr
chairman um i cannot go forward with the
current officer's
um highway author's recommendation which
is such complete conflict with the
previous one
and therefore i'm really not comfortable
with this application despite mr mr
brooks
very clear presentation
you indicated
i can't hear you john
john yeah all right hang on hey
click back on again um he refers to it
as as10 uh i presume that's referring to
it as a small scale development
but a small scale development is always
relevant to the area in which it is
being developed and in my book this is a
very tight
country road um that leads to
probably a very attractive area at the
end and also there's a
a road going on down to the river it's
used as a footpath there is no
footpaths available or pavement
available
in the road so there is the danger of
traffic going along that road
um i don't see it as
uh it affected well the landscape
could be a bit better in that area but i
really don't think that uh
the visual impact under five and nine
warrants giving approval to it and i go
along with what um
my fellow councillor kettle has just
referred to and um in my book it's not
sensitive enough
to warrant granting and i i propose that
that as a proposed
my proposal for
not grant
you're muted chairman don't
don't get at me i was trying to make it
easier because
uh too many people on it affects the
broadband with and people come across
like a dalek
um so i'll bring mr jefferson first and
then we'll go back to your
your proposal thank you so much chair
i know um counselor harvey has has made
some
compelling comments and and they were
persuasive
i i'm slightly concerned that members
are
treating the application um received in
2015
on a different site albeit on mill lane
as being made on
the same application site that we have
before us today that is not the case
um each application must be judged on
its own
merits i think that's worth reiterating
that is what the county highway officer
has done in the case of this application
the amendments to mill lane which have
been proposed by the applicant
the changes to the junction and their
own transport survey which
has been undertaken more recently than
2015
members have the benefit of those
comments and they have been challenged
throughout the lifetime of the
application and i think that it is
telling that highway authority
throughout those
challenges have have maintained their
view um that there shouldn't be an
objection here
on balance on highway safety grounds
and so i think that members really
should take those comments
um on their merits and and treat them as
as the sort of factual
and non-us and the subjective assessment
of highway impacts which they are
members um you also have heard from a
hiring expert in the uh
in the conversation today you have the
opportunity to ask him technical
questions
in respect of um uh access to the site
and i think that that's really
where your consideration should lie
please the message is to assess the
application before you
thank you can i make a further comment
is it as part of a debate or was it well
apart from having a
near accident with the ward member as he
turned into the middle lane
and i was turning out it does underline
the problem of
the junction yeah okay
my concern is as long say
if you read the the report from
from the highways authority
there is a lack of recorded accidents in
that area
and they're the highways authority and
they've been challenged twice by this
i think if that's right mr brooke
you've gone gone back and challenged
them twice to
should they try to come in please sorry
i didn't realize
we've we've gone back to him a few times
regarding character harvey's comments
yeah and they are still
of the opinion that the
visibility displays can be met
with the improvements made to the
junction
and to the application site which is
almost exactly but not the same again to
quote
against the harvest rise so it's
i'm very concerned about challenging
the validity of the request
we've gone back twice and i i don't i
totally disagree with cancer
kettle's comments about going back five
years and it being the same things moved
on five years
and people do leave and as we all know
from from scientists or experts you know
uh one would say something's black the
other will say something that's right
so if the person who
from the county council had given their
opinion no
it's been challenged two or three times
and i still come up with the same answer
things have moved on from five years ago
so
um as chairman so in my opinion i'm
happy to accept
the information from the highways
authority of the experts and this
counselor
harvey quite rightly pointed out he was
there to challenge his ward member he
admitted he's not the highways engineer
and
thank you for that cancer harvey and
that was very clear but you came up with
some points that
were clear and and you're able to
challenge you know challenge
so i'm very concerned about this i'm not
keen for this to be deferred
to go back because um if we did this on
every application
if we set a president saying well five
years ago we had an application
at a nearby site um
where that whether the highways officer
is saying something different
we could be opening the floodgates for
all sorts of all sorts of
deferrals and this is not the way we
should be should be doing things
you know so that's that's my my point
but
um right then chris you want to come
back on on the debate bit
um in most circumstances i would
absolutely agree with you
um uh and um council crumb
um but whilst um
mr richards was quite right to point out
that the other application was on a
separate site the other application was
on the set others on the mill lane
um and therefore uh and it was looking
to increase
one to five houses um and this house
is on mill lane looking from one to five
houses
uh and the issue is not um about access
from this particular site onto mill lane
which would be unique to this site
um it is about access from a long mill
lane
and out on to the what was formerly
known as the
a34 i think it's not called the a3400
um it is still a phenomenally uh busy
road at certain times obviously traffic
at the moment is slightly less
um and having lived in warwickshire and
been driving here for over 40 years
uh i'm fully aware of um the amount of
traffic that can go along there
i i take your point um
in some respects but actually a
professional
member of the county council's opinion
is being disregarded on this side
on on this road and access onto the 3400
it is not um it is not about that
that's my problem in that earlier
evidence he's just being
disregarded because they do not know why
he made the comment
presumably when that comment was made it
was signed off by
a highways manager and therefore had
some validity
uh what i had for support all the county
council at that stage
therefore i accept you don't want to
defer it
but i believe that evidence is as good
as the evidence we have today
because nothing has changed nothing has
changed
on mill lane or on the exit to
the b4 100 though sorry not before the
a3 400
i accept we have a different view mr
chairman neither is going to change our
minds
i think well i think we've got a
graduate side now
we could argue this until the chaos come
home um and and i'm not prepared to do
that
i think we we've had a proposal from
councillor
fielding uh to regret uh reject
the application um but i'm not sure
uh i need some classification i'll
second it
so um need to um i need to
have some clarification of the reasons
for refusal
um under under as10
and i don't look at it as a small
development
on a narrow road it's over development
on that particular road um
five uh if i get it again um
landscaping character development
i can't i can't see that as being of any
value there are trees and hedge grow
hedgerows there um which i hope will not
be
knocked over by the vehicles going down
and they ought to be protected
um and i think it was nine was the other
one
i was concerned about um if i can find
it again
i don't know it didn't give me any
feeling that they were distinctive
designs
or of high quality
and with regards to environment
sustainability again i'm not certain of
would you be adding some uh reasons for
refusal that's rather than a comment or
strengthening counselling
i think i think it's a a refinement on
um mr fielding's comments on the
highways area
um in that the um the conflicting
evidence
we've had from two county council
highways
um experts
uh leaves this um
considerable doubt on uh
this area oh sorry on this application
on its um on the safety of the access
and i'm not prepared to discount the
earlier information so i want to keep
that
i want to keep that ball rolling um
i think in sustains i completely accept
mr brooks comments
and i've already said so um but i
believe that when one has
a allocation um a guidance of
59 houses and we are now already at 99
houses
and the nsv system uh that was
developed final course strategy was
meant to identify sustainability
that we have now reached the threshold
in this settlement
where uh the sustainability criteria
are being pushed beyond uh what is
reasonable
uh oh
yeah um i would certainly um
encourage members not to include
highways um
as a reason for refusal um the as i
mentioned we're judging this application
before us on its merits the previous one
from 2015 hasn't been disregarded by the
county council
they've had regard to it um and they've
they had they offered no objection to
this application and they set out the
reasons why
their viewpoint differs 2015. that's in
the update sheet
um also in relation to numbers um
the lsv numbers again we're talking
about an increase of five here
and the real question is what's the harm
um
of the additional numbers so i would i
would strongly discourage members from
including the
london and highways reasons for refusal
um right uh
i'll bring david did it and then cancer
hunters harryford i can't
um i believe ian wants to speak as well
um thank you
um just to re reiterate really what ross
has said members have not received
conflicting advice from the highway
authority in respect of this planning
application
i think that that is misleading um and
and really needs to be avoided in
respect of any decision making
in respect to this application um
in terms of highways numbers sorry uh
housing numbers uh as as ross
reiterated i think that is a a
misdirection as well
i think that members need to consider
carefully
um sustainability impacts of five
dwellings
in this area there would need to be harm
arising some evidence of heart arising
from
five dwellings in particular on this
site um
in terms of sustainability and the
infrastructure and the services within
the village
your case officers have not been able to
identify that
thank you all right right cancer right
sorry i didn't see you okay that's fine
no my main concern
it's not the development it would be the
narrowness
of the lane with the excess traffic
um would there be any way of making this
lane
wider to accommodate
a doubling of figures of nicaragua's
numbers
that would be my main concern would be
the narrowness of the line where people
have got to walk
reversing up and down it just seems a
lot to me i've got no objections about
the development
itself it's the lying to me is the
problem
uh chair if i may just interject there
i'm sure members are familiar with the
agenda at page 19
it details what the highway authority
would expect in terms of conditions
it were this to be approved um point one
of those conditions requires
the widening of the highway middle name
thanks chad thank you
right um we've had a proposal um
catch the fielding um
there's been four i think there was four
including cancer kettle suggestion
reasons for refusal uh one of which
related to highways which we said advice
from a legal officer
we've also had advice on mr jeffrey
about the housing numbers in terms of
sustainability
and however that would be um
so do you still want to go ahead with
those four points
or will you um
what what's his proposal you you i want
to your
opinion on those please um going back on
to
19 page 19. it refers to
whitening at the junction but doesn't
apart from putting passing places in
it doesn't refer to any other widening
the the carriage is narrow you've got
developments on either side
and you've got a hedgehog well you've
got developments on one side
and you've got a hedge on the other side
um i can't see it can be widened to
allow cast
vehicles to pass on it so it is a
problem
uh also there's a riding stables at the
top end there
and again if they want to ride down the
track um
it brings in another element of danger
again that was not part of the
application and again
i'm concerned about that that's validity
as well
um i appreciate that but it is the lane
that is the problem
right um i think we better go to the
vote i'm just
very concerned the way this is going and
with the
with with the reasons for refusal to be
honest but
we're eating an impulse here um
so chair i think we're before before the
vote can i just
look to clarify the reasons that members
are voting on
uh seconded yep okay david yeah
thank you so i i've taken four week four
reasons for refusal
the first reason for refusal um
i gather is on in respect of as10 um
the view is that this is not a small
scale development within the countryside
and within the width of the road
due to the number of dwellings
and the width of the road this is not
small scale
that's what's um
the second reason i've gathered is in
respect of landscape
um i understand councillor fielding and
you might need to provide a little
further detail for me there
well it's because there's a fairly high
hedge and you couldn't get around the
back of it
it was difficult to see what the
landscape was like but it didn't seem
um it seemed to be again over
development for the landscape
of a very pleasant area that is now
rapidly becoming over developed
it's the site all falling within the
built-up area boundary
i appreciate it i appreciate it you felt
the loss
the loss of the open space associated
with the garden land
for the dwelling yeah um was harmful to
the landscape and character and amenity
of the
area
sorry excuse me i'll just take these
notes
[Music]
and then the third reason um
i gathered from you is that you
considered that the proposed development
was not high quality
and not sensitive due to um
the poor elevations of of the proposed
dwellings
well if you look at the properties on
either side they are uh
or particularly the the new one just
being built that is
a fairly substantial mansion and has a
high degree of um
what's the words um character and the
the house on the other side again uh
has the same um character in my opinion
so
it's not in keeping with those two
properties on either side
yeah so not in key i mean not in
character um
not sensitive uh to the neighbouring
development and therefore in conflict
with policy cs9 not soon
the fourth reason would be
in respect of the access
as discussed
and then the fifth reason
um as offered from councillor kettle
uh is in respect of uh housing numbers
i'm happy with i'm happy with them thank
you
welcome we'll go to the vote
okay chairman councillor crump
so um just so we're clarifying it while
we're speaking on
the um no sorry it is my fault um we
need to
we are voting on councillor building's
proposal to refuse the application
and i can counsel will be voting
against thank you chairman
councillor councillor fielding for
the um refusal councillor fleming
cancer fleming for the refusal
counsellor henshaw seraphin
sorry i can't hear you
all right four for the refusal
thank you and councillor kettle
uh councillor kettle for the proposal
thank you chairman that's four votes for
and one against
right committee
uh recommends uh what's the right word
ross sorry committee
agrees committee resolves to refuse to
application chair sorry i just had a
brain i couldn't think of the right word
uh committee resolves to refuse the
applications for the reasons mentioned
right we'll move on to our next
item on the agenda gentlemen we'll take
a five
minute adjournment for speakers to call
in yeah
no problem this yeah thank you chairman
you weren't waffling because of your
headmistress coming on next no
i don't know it's not that one no right
five minutes then if we could be back by
1918 councillors can i just remind you
all that we're going to share this slide
that lets the members of the public know
that we are adjourning but the meeting
is still live
and you can still be heard so we're
going to mute you all and share the
slides
right are we nearly all back
i'm here
thank you peter present
good
catch the mills i've never been away
yes i'm here mr chairman thank you
castells
come back
cancer fielding is black
no jokes about brooms please and
sleeping under the carpet or
brush it aside nothing like that please
no no
no lizzy okay you
we all ready to go again
ross you okay
right now move on to the next item
on the agenda which is good notification
twenty zero zero five four seven ot
broome junction former railway station
high street
and this is the one where i believe
we've got eddie presenting this one is
that right eddie
that's correct yeah good match should be
showing now
yep that is working thank you yep sean
thanks chair
this is an outline application for one
dwelling with all matters reserve
barring access the site is located
around 220
meters from the western edge of broome
as denoted here
with the red line it is indicative at
the moment so there is a dwelling shown
on the site but
that it would be reserved for a later
stage if the outline was approved
this is some indicative floor plans and
elevations of the proposed dwellings so
if mission was fourth come in um this is
a potential dwelling
size that they would be looking at
again this shows the application site
outlined in red
with the public right of way al-17
run into the western boundary broom is
shown here
to the east beyond the river arrow
and finally here's a few shots uh the
top two
uh from within the site showing the
general context and
some of the surrounding areas uh the
bottom right photo
is of the accessing to the site from the
highway
and the bottom left one is also from the
access but looking back towards
uh broom in the distance updates
include one technical question from
councillor fielding
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
for the reasons detailed on page 29
thank you
chairman i believe you muted
sorry i failed again mr kennedy uh
are you with us you're our first speaker
please
good evening chairman thank you mr
candidate you've got three minutes and
if you can stay with us in case there
are any questions after your
presentation and if
we'll give you a warning with 30 seconds
to go and far away when ready please
okay thank you thank you for angus to
speak in support of the application
we're disappointed that the
recommendation to the committee is to
refuse outline consent we feel that the
development will bring an area of
previously developed land close to the
village centre back into a beneficial
and viable use
the previous use of the site as a
railway station is part of the heritage
of the village
the proposed development will revive the
site and will do so in a way that
properly acknowledges its previous use
and the character of the surrounding
area
the objection to the proposal is based
on the principle of the development
policy as10 of the core strategy is
referred to in the committee report
we ask that the committee take the
following matters into consideration
before determining the application
the the strategic aim of policy as-10
is to maintain and enhance the rural
character of the area
the introduction to the policy refers to
the provision of a wide range of
activities and development in the rural
parts of the district
it goes on to refer to the need to
minimise the impact of development
on the character of the landscape and to
prioritise the reuse of brainfield land
the development although not falling
within any of the categories of
residential developments at 18 policy
as-10
achieves the objectives of the policy by
improving the character of the landscape
and bringing a brownfield site close to
the village center back into use
the particular merits of this case
outweigh the issues raised in the
committee report
and bring forward special circumstances
that will allow the development to take
place without conflicting with it with
this with the strategic objectives of
policy
or setting any precedent for
inappropriate development to be allowed
elsewhere in the district
the site is previously developed land
the buildings within the site have been
damaged by vandalism
but the platform track and access
remains and
trackline surrey and access remain in
situ these are dominant
features that confirm the previous use
of the site and stand out within the
landscape
the remains of the previous development
have not been absorbed to become part of
the landscape
there is a distinct difference between
the site and the fields that
that surround it this accentuates the
commercial character of the site and
distinguishes it from the rural fields
beyond
care is being taken to providing it to
provide a indicative design of property
that respects the former railway station
use of the site
and will not have a greater impact on
openness in the buildings that
previously stood on it
a balance needs to be struck between the
advantages of developing the site
and the criteria certain policy asp
the development will replace buildings
lost to lost to vandalism
with a dwelling that respects the
context and heritage of the area
the future of the site looks bleak and
less a suitable use can be found for it
the proposed development makes efficient
use of the site and will improve the
overall setting of the land
in and around the site we would urge the
committee to take these matters into
consideration
and grant outline plan outline planning
consent to develop the site with a
single dwelling thank you
right thank you very much mr kennedy
any questions please for the agent
uh cancel the fielding
i think i'm not muted unlike our
chairman
um the design or the rough
indication of the design um
being on a railway line is that
meant to look a little bit like a
station house
yes um members may be aware that there
was an
application that was submitted um during
last year
which didn't include any elevations
whatsoever that was withdrawn before
it was um before before it was
determined i became involved at that
point
i met the applicant on site and looking
at the site i think well
the history of it is as a railway
station we put photographs in the
planning statement to show what type of
buildings were on the site previously
and what we've tried to do is show that
you could replicate or get a
or get a sense of the feel of those type
of buildings that were there previously
they were single stories simple gable
gable end buildings and that's what
that's what we've tried to replicate
here
we thought that was right rather than
trying to look at a country house type
type of design it's trying to it's
trying to find something which
acknowledges the heritage of the area is
it on the footings of the
old building uh
yes it's actually on the platform itself
thank you cancer cattle
could you um just um explain
what the what what liaison you had with
salford prize
parish council they haven't attended and
not speaking but it'd be helpful to hear
your interpretation of their view um
they made comments on the previous
application as as i understand
um the not myself the applicant
um contacted them i believe um to
actually
explain what was what was proposed on
the site
um and since then um they have not
commented have made
i think it was no representation or no
objection to this
to this application so they we actually
informed them when the application was
going back in
as to what the application was and what
was actually proposed thank you
yeah i love it
right i don't think there's any further
questions thank you mr neil
you are free to go but stay with us
thank you thanks right we'll now move on
to our
next speaker which is cancer flowing
who's the ward member
chancellor fleming are you with us yeah
i'm with you well i used to be with the
woolies but i'll be with you um
give me your age while you're there
counselor
there you go um right um i've got a bit
of a written statement and it won't be
full of technical
uh clauses and various other stuff um i
think it
really relates to the site and the
history of the site to give it a bit of
depth
um i uh
the site's been derelict for a long time
it was closer majors
junction in the early 1960s lay empty
for a long time
and the buildings were still in place
and it was used as a roadstone depot for
warwickshire county council
i am very familiar with this site as i
used to live 250 metres away from it for
15 years
i still only live a mile and a half now
over the years the abandonment and
subject vandalism meant that the
buildings were demolished mid 1980s
the sites had varying interests over the
years and also being a paris council for
broome and bridgford and chair of the
planning committee
we've seen interest from heavy haulage
companies but there are no easy exit
routes to the major a roads available
so it's totally unsuitable for any other
users as we see it
the site is outside the parish the
boundary of bidford parish
and within salford price parish i
actually attended the salford prize pc
meeting where this application was
discussed
and with the produce the production of
an up-to-date fra
the pc offered no objection i personally
discussed
this application with the residence in
the closest vicinity
uh just at the other side the river for
the application that's currently been
made
not one of those people objected and
were in fact relieved that it could be a
dwelling in the style of the old 19th
century
station rather than the previous
interest for road haulage
as things now stand there are no
objections or concerns from warwickshire
county council
visibility sways traffic is slowing
preparing to enter the 30 mile an hour
zone which is only
50 meters from the entrance and after
submission of the lotus
latest fra which was slow to be
acknowledged the dwelling sites been
reclassified as zone 1
requiring no intervention from the
environment agency have removed their
previous objection
the bidford parish ndp argument is
irrelevant as the site is in salford
prior paris
i find it astonishing that the mention
of no school shops etc is detrimental
where was this argument when five houses
were built on a brownfield site in the
last 18 months
only 150 metres away so we have a
private individual who works in the area
who wants to build a family home in a
very sympathetic style
on a previously designated brownfield
site with no objection from any of the
relevant advisory agencies
it's eco-compliant and that's why i
support this and we'll ask the committee
members to grant this application
if you look at the uh the
information on page 26
it says summary of relevant history
no none relevant i think the history of
the site
is absolutely relevant and also
if you look under consultations
environment environment agency no
objection works to county council no
objection
uh ecology no objection wcc rights away
no objection
sdc environmental health no objection
so from that perspective i'm trying
really hard to work out about this this
uh green and open countryside that was
for 150 years almost um a very heavy
duty
railway station and uh in in fairness to
what
uh what's being proposed i think it'll
be a tremendous asset to the area
and so if we're only here to judge
what's relevant
um the plans for the extreme end of the
site have an eco-friendly wild garden
zones planned
but uh from my perspective i can't see
any reason at all
why this should be refused and i would
urge the committee
to support the uh to support the
recommendation to be
to be granted thank you
chairman you're muted still
the mills did you take your glasses off
while you're waving
no right well i've got one cancer
flowing um
it's it's to do really with the support
um
uh you said you spoke to neighbours
who were relieved that um i think
relieve was the phrase
that something was happening um
but none of those appear to have written
in supporting the application
and obviously that the same applies for
the paris council there was no
no objection but again there was no no
support
for this application from them and if
they really were concerned about
that area and again the agent mentions
historical heritage
quite a lot um you would have thought
they would have been supportive of the
application
um and i've seen i just wondered why
um why did why they didn't do it and why
there wasn't any letters to support
binge you had spoken to people as well
who were relieved about it
uh well if you if you still look at
looking at the slides
that shows the uh the site to the left
i spoke to the people on the immediate
housing development
straight across that field and behind
the row of trees
and they're the most people most
directly affected but
what you have to bear in mind is where
that river is
is the boundary between bidford paris
council
and salford prior parish council to get
from this site
into salford priors takes 12 minutes to
drive there
and it's two and a half miles away this
is the absolute extreme outpost
of salford prize parish council um so
from that perspective it has absolutely
no effect on salford prius
as a a as a an entity in terms of the
village so
in reality i was actually at the paris
council meeting when they they went for
no objection
and so they have nothing
they really don't have a point to make
really because at the end of the day
they've got no objection because
it doesn't affect them in any material
way whatsoever
the road is referred to the high street
um
is there why the if it's outside the
village why is that referred to
as the high street uh and what sort of
distance is it to the
uh restriction speed restriction sign
should we do those at technical
questions for the officer
i would say speed split restriction sign
is about 50 meters from the main
entrance
just before the river bridge
okay cancer building
right i don't there's any further
questions
sorry john are you um i was agreeing
with you that
uh i didn't have any further questions
okay thank you thank you council fleming
you're free to go we'll
we'll now move on to the debate on this
one who wants to come in on this one
chair technical questions questions
oh sorry i was um yes
technical questions in my haste to get
finished before the full moon appears
um any technical questions to uh
eddie please yep
far away uh can i draw attention to page
27
and the third paragraph
where the officer
sets out the criteria for compliance
with
as10 and concludes that in effect
none of the criteria are met
i presume it was well known to
the officer that this was a railway site
and it did have a building on it
and it was demolished in the 1980s or
thereabouts
and i was on the one hand i'm i'm
reluctant
to see um uh
a proposal uh a proposal to conflict
which conflicts with um
uh policy uh approved and um i'm
i'm minded to go along with the the
officer's recommendation
however um i think uh councillor
fleming's
contribution illustrates the degree of
local support and the lack of objections
from
all and sundry my question is
one of the correct two of the criteria
are replacement dwellings
and the second one redevelopment of bad
neighborhood
site in the context of this application
could the officer please explain um
why this application couldn't be
squeezed
in under compliance
with replacement dwelling since there
was a dwelling on the site at one stage
or the replacement or redevelopment of a
bad
neighborhood site this isn't the most
attractive site and it's looking for
a use yep uh
sorry am i i'm not muted am i you can't
hear me
no i can hear you yeah yeah um
so the first one in terms of a
replacement dwelling um
it's not my understanding that there was
a dwelling there but
even if it if there was a times past
it's obviously being demolished for many
years
um you know it's reverted basically back
to a railway station so
in terms of our replacement dwelling
policy is purely for dwellings that are
in current use
have a use as a dwelling um obviously
this has been demolished for many years
so
it wouldn't meet that criteria in terms
of bad neighbor uses
um those are generally the ones that
i've dealt with
we're talking about really um
you know we're talking about whether
animals are being killed
or you know horrific noises or
significant environmental health issues
you know this this site is purely an
abandoned site
that's been overgrown and left for a
long time but it doesn't really cause
bad neighbor is where you're really
talking about someone's
health and well-being being
detrimentally impacted
from that site so it's really those
those circumstances are really in the
extreme of affecting neighbors and
obviously in those instances
i think you would have you know
neighbors up in arms about yeah let's
get it developed and redeveloped
whereas obviously here we you know we've
got very minimal neighbor contacts
neighbor comments sorry so i certainly
wouldn't feel it it met that criteria
again picking up on your earlier point
about
previously developed land and brownfield
in terms of the policy set out in as10
um you know well so we we can
acknowledge that part of it may be and
some of it might not be
previously dire planned it's almost not
necessarily part of the key issues under
as10
as as they're set out for residential
you know
if one of those ones included in terms
of our policies that we've set out
if there was one for a previously
developed land allowing for
dwellings it would be within that policy
and as they're set out today
there isn't that exception that would
allow a dwelling in this location
and the officer in this in this occasion
has looked at all the
applicable policies or instances where
residential development
is allowed in this instance and in this
case
it doesn't fall within any of those
instances so it's almost
whether it's previously developed land
or not is not necessarily the issue
purely in terms of as-10
thank you very much thank you councillor
mills
please thank you mr chairman um
eddie um the um it's got their flood
risk
and is there a great flood risk here
is it flat west too well i think there
was um
in reading through the history of what's
happened on the application i think it
was originally
shown on the ea's website that nearly
all of the site was within
two uh flood zones two and three but
subsequently a um
flood risk assessment was done by the
applicant which showed
different data analysis that actually
showed the real
um flooding risk at the site um
was less than a previously known and
that followed
the environment agency withdrawing their
original
objection to the proposals as the as it
stands they have
withdrawn their objections subject to
certain conditions and i think
one of those is that it would need to
lie within flood zone 1 which
at least a portion of the site does does
now
fit that criteria thanks eddie that's
great thank you
cancer fielding
there we go um under the
brownfield site element of this i know
that
most of the definition under as11
is for large-scale developments but this
was very much used um
for transport storage or
building uh road work storage it was
also um there are also very strong signs
there
of where the original building was
and also part of the
area where the sidings were uh in this
in this development that to me is
comes out as a classical brownfield site
i don't know if there's any pollution
there
um if there is uh in the siding area
that could be investigated but
under as10 it's a small scale
development in open
well not in open country cycles part
traditionally being part
of the village it's um has very good
access on the question john please
sorry i'm waffling i know um
i don't understand can you please give
more detail on why
it's not a brownfield site
i i don't think it's not necessarily a
case of saying it is or isn't brownfield
site it's purely under as10 one of the
criteria that allows for dwelling it
isn't part of making an assessment of
where it's a brownfield site
in the open countryside i think you know
just
looking at the history and obviously
what's happened and looking at some of
the photos i would say that certainly
some of it is previously developed
but whether the the the entire extent of
it is now
under the the definition in the glossary
of the mppf
you know is up for debate but
that wouldn't overcome the in principle
objection of it not meeting any of the
criteria for residential development
in this location which is outside of
outside of a village which isn't an lsv
as well so it isn't all other settlement
it's outside that it's um at the moment
there's no path into broome as well so
we do
you know envisions that nearly all
journeys would need to be made by
you know private vehicle so there's
there's issues
around that as well just by where it's
located coming to
policy as11 where you're talking about
realm
large or brownfield sites that policy is
specifically to do with very large sites
where we're
talking you know multiple houses
you know the sites it mentions the you
know we're talking about gaiden
lighthorn he
i accept that so they're purely to do
with almost where
they create new settlements of such a
scale they bring sustainability measures
with them you know where
shops and things might be attracted to
the very large sites
the smaller sites certainly for one
dwelling it does it wouldn't bring any
of those benefits where you'd expect
under policy
under sites under as as11
in that case um so so that's sort of
where officers are coming from it's not
denying that it's not brownfield site
and there's obviously benefits
in in simplistic terms of promoting
development to these sites over
greenfield sites
it's just that it purely being brown a
previously developed
site or partly doesn't overcome the
locational issues that are raised
through as
10 in terms of where housing should be
located
can i have a quick follow-up very quick
junk so i want to
move on on this one please yeah you
refer to the historical
element of it historically it's broome
station it's always been part and parcel
with broome and uh it's
in my book it is part of the um
area of rumor itself but anyway
that is i leave that as it is it's not a
question i'm sorry
oh sorry right cancel the kettle please
chris are you here
no no chris can you hear me
can i see the kettle uh
yeah it was just um sorry butthole
[Music]
withdrawn okay yeah thank you
right now move on to the debate please
who wants to start on this one
catch the mills please
thank you mr chairman thank you um
well this is interesting the site i i
i think the uh i mean just looking at
the design of it uh
is very very pleasing and i think
they're on the right track for this one
oh yeah yes seriously
i think um no platforming please
yes i'm sorry uh is it
harmful i i don't believe it is
um i have to say
it is it to me it's making use of a of a
derelict site i mean what's going to
happen to
it if it's not being made to use i'll be
just a yeah
a bit of a scrub land um i'm sorry eddie
um i i'm going against the officer's uh
recommendation for um refuse so uh
mr chairman thank you cancer
cancer kettle please um
i've been to look at the site um i
completely accept um
mr wrench's comments that this is
um a former built site uh and therefore
you know it's not the site that
but it is as as has said
it's a scruffy little bit of backland um
i use that word not technically
um it is outside the village
um and that and it doesn't really fit in
with as-10
um but what else is going to happen to
this land
here here we have an opportunity uh to
do something sensible with it
um which would be better than a previous
previous uses assault dump or a
county council dump um and if it is
we wait to see what what what might come
out of it in terms of a
um reserve matters
um it's set that well from the highway
it's on an established access onto the
highway if you look at all the new
objections
and in particular from the parish
and um um
nobody's objecting to this whit apart
from the central council
uh under as to ten um and in a way
and i've quoted council of previous
district council williams
you know if it's not quite right it's
wrong but i think in the other way
this is the other way around there's an
awful lot going forward
uh towards it um and whilst it may not
fit neatly into as10
i i i think on this one
what else we're going to do on site and
i think this is the best option for it
mr chairman
okay um
um the
yeah my thoughts one we've got policies
and
you know we've gone through the policies
that we had
gone through a long time to get these
policies and i think this clearly
contradicts our policies
secondly i would go on the council that
williams's speech you just mentioned
cancer kettle
if it's not wrong if it's not right it's
wrong
and because we've got the housing
numbers we've got housing nun supply
i don't think we need to rush in getting
something from this application
um and for this site so again
there's you're saying what might not we
might have nothing else come up for it
uh and therefore we should should be
doing it against policy so i i disagree
with that
um cancer harvey earlier mentioned about
support um support of the community from
um in cancer fleming's speech again i
can see
no support from the community
there was no objection from the parish
council um
and cancer fleming explained why but
again if i
had some concerns about this they wanted
to use this
historical site um they would have said
yes
bring this back in we've not had
anything for on this site for ages so
yeah i'm happy to support this but they
didn't so that was quite telling
and there's been no letters of support
from the immediate neighbours as well
so i'm really concerned about this
um we've also got no
footpath previous application we were
talking about lack of footpaths and
danger and walking
and okay it's not such a significant
road maybe but again
we've got the principle that's outside
the compounds of the village
uh and we were happy for people to walk
in but which is contradictory to the one
we did before so
i'm very concerned about this and as you
can tell i will be supporting the
officers a recommendation to refuse
so i'll bring cancer hunter serif in in
on this one
yes thank you chair um i visited this
site
over the years not not but long before i
became a counselor
and i was always in the belief that
something could be built on here
that enhanced the historical
station that was there and i
think that the application should be
granted and i propose
i'll propose this now won't dwell
that this application be granted
and we'll come back to the reasons you
will come back to the reasons in a
minute then
uh catch the uh
fielding uh you will want to speak yeah
um one of the things that
was brought up by uh the ward member was
the fact that the
gentleman who has put this application
in
works in the village i believe he also
lives in the village
and his family live in the village
it is very much um a tight community
even the ward member knows and remembers
this is a
very much uh an area where
when he was young enough to remember he
got chased off by the
guards i believe we should grant it it's
getting rid of a bit of gasland
and as10 um should be brought in on this
and also landscaping and i believe
um a house that if he is proposing it
along the lines of the station
house then that could be a distinctive
developer
we've got a lot of conjecture here and
that's what i'm concerned about yeah we
should be basing this on planning
applications and facts
um so i'm really concerned about this
we've got policies it's outside
we've not got paths or footpaths into
the village we'll be creating car
journeys
um potentially three cars there
because on the previous application we
had five houses and people were talking
about 15
uh cars so on this location we'd have an
extra three cars down
uh really narrow road so i'm just very
concerned about this again
um but uh
council kettle no we're not we're on on
the debate now we're not got question
for a technical question i've so we'll
i'm going to move on
um mr jeffrey could you just come in on
that one please
yes thank you chair um i just need to
draw members attention to the
um top page 27 the principle of
development
it makes the point very clearly that
council is required to make a decision
in line with the development
plan um i have to say i i get it in the
neck when my officers forget to put this
line
in their reports from mesa nash and
other people in legal because this is a
lawful point to make
in our planning committee reports
members need to make their decisions
based on planning policy in this respect
your officers have identified
that although this is a brownfield site
it sits outside
of any built up area boundary
there is not a policy within aes 10
which supports
housing on brownfield sites wherever
they may be
cs 15 provides a spatial hierarchy of
where
this council would like to see
development directed within the district
it starts with stratford it goes to the
main rural centers
and then it goes to local service
villages um
councillor kettle on the previous
application was talking in detail about
what level of development might be
appropriate within the local service
village
this falls outside of any local service
village it is some distance away in fact
broome as eddie pointed out in his
comments
is not a local service village it has no
services
sufficient to make it such so that is
not a location where this authority
would support development even if it
were in
the confines of broome this site sits
outside of that it is not connected to
broome with a footpath as
councillor crump has pointed out it is
uh for all intents and purposes
a brownfield site in the open
countryside
your officers have advised you how the
core strategy
applies to such sites within the agenda
report
i think members as as you need to look
to your policies
and consider how those impact this
proposal
thank you mr chairman um
can i just say in in cs16
um after they go through the
rural brownsville sites approximately
1254 homes
there is a category of other rural
locations of approximately 750 homes
um i completely get what
mr jeffrey has just said because
i would really like him just to come
back if i play mr chairman you may not
allow it
but i'd really like to come back and
just explain
what that other rural locations category
means in the core strategy
and as to whether under cs16 combined
with cs1
a sustainable development
we've had the debate i think we'll go to
we've
um i'm happy for to move on and again
i think um well i don't know what 750 at
what what 750 rural homes in other
locations means i'm just
i'm asking for some advice i mean i
don't like confirming if you want me to
do that quickly
those what i just do very quickly under
as10 there's obviously a number of
dwelling types that are allowed in those
rural areas which includes within
small villages that aren't necessarily
sv's replacement dwellings all those
those are the dwelling types that
constitute that part of
cs16
right right then um
did have we had a proposal on this we've
gone on for a while
yeah um council hence the terrifying yes
you
you did but we we're going to come back
to the region
please can you remove the image so we
can see everyone's charming face
oh no i prefer the image
[Laughter]
right um yeah so can't say
serif we might have proposed all to
grant this application
um now we need some
some really funny reasons well as these
people
already live in the village of broome
and this
would enhance the area of where
this brownfield site which was a railway
station
i see no objection of refusing it
it's uh it's it's going forward and it
looks a lovely design
which would match what the station was
there
so i i stick by what i say i
propose that grant that's granted yes
cancer harvey
can you hear me trevor yes
are we still debating or are we going to
go to the vote no
i'm happy to for you to bring in on the
debate sorry i didn't pick you up
that's my apologies um
my my view is that we have policies
and mr jeffrey eloquently set out the
reasons
for those policies um
mr wrench uh satisfactorily answered my
question
and although they may or may it may or
may not be popular locally
to make use of this site the blunt fact
is
it does not comply with our policy
and on that basis i shall be voting
against
uh in favor of refusal and against
acceptance
thank you councillor harvey uh ross
can you comment on this please
yeah i was just going to comment chair
on councillor um hensha seraphin's
reasons for grant redevelopment of a
brownfield site
that's that's fair enough um he
mentioned the people
live in the village well that's
immaterial it doesn't matter who the
applicant is
um so i would ask members to disregard
that um
a few people a few councillors have
mentioned the
um the sort of indicative design
of the proposed dwelling just to bear in
mind this is an outline application with
all matters reserved
so that that those drawings are purely
indicative that's not
no guarantee that that's the um that's
the design that will come forward
thanks
right uh
is everybody happy that
the debate is over
so we've got a proposal with
from cancer sorry peter he called you
peter then consensual servant
and that's with one reason to the one
reason
you're happy ken sanchez cereben um
except mr chambers advice
about that yes but uh
i'll still um provoke grant
yeah we have no problem yeah we've just
got one one
condition one sorry um
do do we uh after the should we do the
conditions after the vote
uh no no i'd like to um
have those part of the resolution please
if possible
go on then david what conditions would
you apply if this was
approved um i recommend the
standard outline conditions requiring a
time limit
and submission of reserve matters
i'd seek to require a condition
that stipulates there'd be no more than
one dwelling on the site
let's seek for a condition which sought
compliance with the climate change
spd as part of the submission of any
reserve matters
given members were somewhat persuaded by
the indicative layout
and elevation that's been provided i
think a condition
seeking that any reserve matters
relating to layout and appearance should
be in general accordance
with those indicative plans provided
i would like a condition which sought
for the applicant to
provide a plan which defines the
cartilage
of the new dwelling as part of a reserve
matters relating to layout
um i would like the development to
have a condition which requires it to
accord with the flood risk assessment
and any conditions um required by the
environment agency
like a condition that requires
landscaping
and biodiversity improvements in any of
the areas which are
non um landscaped cartilage areas
additionally uh i would like environment
electric vehicle charging points um
our standard condition relating to bins
and our standard condition
relating to water butts i'd like if i
may to
offer the case officer any wrench an
opportunity to chip in if he thinks
there's anything else
yeah there was one more i had uh dave
which was a contamination
environmental health uh picked up one
point in terms of
site contamination given the previous
use um
so that was one that i had
um but no i think you mentioned all the
other ones i was going to say so yeah
good so yeah additionally a con a set of
conditions i imagine
relating to any necessary land
contamination investigation
remediation and making good of the land
in general
thank you okay we've had a proposal to
grant this application
uh when the democrat counts the failing
your second did it yeah
can't hear
not unmuting thank you i'll second
yep i was playing around with my mute
unfortunately it wasn't me
right we've had a proposal to and a
second to grant this application
when the democratic services officer
calls out your name please vote for
against or abstain thank you chairman
councillor crump against
councilor mills four
councillor fielding four
councillor harvey against
councillor hensha seraphin
and councillor kettle abstain
that's three votes for chairman two
votes
against and one abstention
okay council resolves to grant
application
twenty zero zero five four seven ut
and will be having uh another break
before the next um
yes please chairman thank you
the first speaker um is everybody back
president present
okay
well that's it yeah i'm here
i think we've got cancer flaming you're
here i can't see you oh yes i'm here
yes i mean i can see everybody's picture
apart from you
so you're hiding i don't know where
you're hiding but
um right i've been
told that everybody's back now still
move on to our next item
which is application 20 slash
00361 which
is 452
westfield crescent was born and our
case officer is louise casey
thank you louise thank you sir
um let me just get this on the screen
can everybody see that
yes we can say that yeah brilliant yes
super so the application now before
members
seeks outline permission for the
construction of one dwelling with all
matters reserved except for access and
landscaping
the application site is outlined here in
red and comprises land to the north of
number 52
westfield crescent and is situated
within the village of wells born
so here we've got an indicative proposed
site layout
as you can see the development would
involve the demolition of an existing
site extension to number 52
which is shown on the plan here in
yellow
the development will also make use of
the existing access point into the site
so apologies now
turning to images of the application
site
top left we've got number 52 westfield
present
uh top right shows number 52 again here
in context to the surrounding nearby
residential dwellings
bottom left here is taken from the
stratford road which is to the north of
the site and is looking forward to
looking towards the existing side of
number 52.
um bottom right here is also taken from
the stratford road and illustrates views
again from this vantage point so you can
see the rear elevation of
number 52 just there so to conclude
the application site is situated within
the built-up area boundary of wells born
and is considered acceptable in
principle
matters of access and landscaping have
been considered acceptable subject to
conditions
matters of appearance layout and scale
are not matters for debate at this
committee
they would be subject to a further
application should this one be approved
so chairman is recommended to grant the
application uh for the reasons set out
within the report
in terms of updates uh there's a couple
so the report contained a a
a minor mistake which incorrectly
detailed counselor parry as the ward
member natural facts counselor kendall
um and also the black dot was missing
from the one to twenty five thousand map
within the agenda pack
uh but the updated map uh has been
appended to the update sheet um and
there was also a technical question from
councillor harvey and i'd refer you to
again to the update sheet to read that
question and the response from
the officer thank you very much thank
you
louise i'll never bring our first
speaker
in which is cancer the prior from
wellsborne and walton paris council
hello good evening cancer prior i'll see
you know the form
you've got three minutes and we'll give
you a warning shot with
three minutes to go absolutely 30
seconds to go
far away when you're ready please okay
thank you very much
good evening councillors um westfield
crescent is a pleasant small development
of well-spaced semi-detached and
detached houses
with well-tended front gardens and some
communal green space
on the immediate edge of the
conservation area and on a major route
into
and out of the village this proposed
development does not match the existing
housing
it is not in line with the current
street scene it's an example of
land grabbing but is not sympathetic to
the surrounding area
and the council feels it is an
overdevelopment of the site
whilst the officer states that this is
just an outline planning application
showing the landscaping if approved it
opens the way for the full development
and future presentation of the reserve
matters
we would ask that it is refused at this
stage before the damage of
overdevelopment can occur
the landscaping is referred it referred
to in the officers report
but that seems to consist of hedging
outside the fence
and some grass there is no attempt to
mitigate the large expanse of tarmac
that will be created to make four
parking spaces
two for the existing building and two
for the proposed building these parking
spaces are confined
small and look difficult to access with
the close proximity they have to each
other
and their creation leads to the loss of
a significant amount of green space
we would ask that the committee protects
what is a very pleasant residential
development
from this inappropriate planning
application and refused permission at
this stage
if not done now it will happen in some
form in the future
once outlined consenting outline consent
is given
and be detriment be detrimental to the
area we would ask that you refuse it
thank you counselor prior any questions
for the ward member
sorry for the the parish police
well just i've got one very brief on
council prior
um i noticed that some the ward member
didn't
object and there's been no neighbor
representations
um i've just wondered whether you
whether you'd spoken to any of the
neighbors or the parish council spoken
to any other neighbours
regardless of location we had some in
the earlier
application because there was a previous
application where some of the residents
were not happy
the ward member hasn't made presentation
because of his status on the other
planning committee obviously
yeah so you know yeah i shouldn't have
mentioned the other award member that
was that's my fault
it was just um just the neighbors so now
you've answered that thank you so
apologist for my uh i mentioned in the
award number
rent any other questions
for cancer prior
no and i i did one
point of note we have we will be writing
to you because we've got another
application
um that you'll be speaking to at the end
we have tried to move you around to
bring you closer together but
unfortunately due to the technical
difficulties we're having we weren't
able to do that we would have been able
to do that that um
elizabeth had so apologies for this and
the planning manager will be
writing to the parish council to explain
this so i just thought
let you know that so i did try and as
you can remember when i was at school
i was very trying indeed you were
so apologies for that okay
thank you right uh we'll now move on
to technical questions for the opposite
police
[Music]
any any questions for the officer
councillor harvey then counts the mills
can i just be reassured that if this
application is granted
that there would be no objection on the
grounds that the
garden is the remaining garden is too
small
does it
uh yet that has been considered a
counsellor and we do have
um some guidance on garden areas and i'm
satisfied that the
remaining garden area for number 52
would be sufficient for the
immunity of the occupiers of that
dwelling
thank you thank you louise cancer mills
please
hi louise um you you did so
i'm sure if i missed the point did you
say uh
side extensions could be taken down 52
yeah that's throughout access no no it's
just to
uh basically allow a larger area for a
new dwelling
to uh go in that location um i can
if i get a picture if you could please
yeah
yeah of course let me just
so um can you see the photos there so
top left is number one
and you can see that side extension and
the bottom
left as well you can see a lot clearer
in order to facilitate the development
that extension would be
removed so that there is a larger area
to essentially
um cite the new dwelling that's proposed
and louise i don't
what's that extension we can see there
now
was that the original part of the house
or was that
something being put on afterwards no
that that
has been extended since the development
originally went up with all the all the
houses that's electricity so that
that is right okay
uh thank you i i i'm sad just yeah okay
thank you
thank you think against the males cast
the kettle please
sorry mr chairman i'm having slightly
communication problems here
um i'm just going
to ask okay could you repeat
you said to council mills i have got
identical question i know you've
answered it but
my my my volume my noise went completely
silent um and again the question is that
uh extension to the existing property is
going to be removed
yes that's correct thank you
right uh counselor
and yourself and please oh yes uh
louise can i ask just one question um
this side extension coming down with the
new development
are related to family members
you know of information as part of the
application hasn't hasn't
stipulated that uh so um i
i don't have an answer who it would be
for that's not been provided
okay thank you
right thank you very much uh we'll now
move on
let's have a look we'll then move on to
the debate please
who wants to um start on this one
quick question is the chairman hiding
for any reason
it's uh what connection is flying up a
little bit and i thought yeah he'd
rather hear me than see me so
all right cancer cattle
thank you for that um i i originally had
had concerns about um
alongside the parish council this was a
development site
but i think in view of the fact that the
um
existing extension is coming down which
will therefore reflect
leave that house looking like the other
ones um
clearly it is slightly squeezing a point
um
according to a pint pot um but we've
heard from the planning officer uh
it is liable to meet all the
requirements that we're supposed to meet
with
and therefore um it's not quite where i
started off but i think i'm
uncomfortable support the officer's
recommendation
[Music]
i'm very happy to listen to other people
before making a proposal but if you want
me to make a proposal
i would support it yes okay thank you
thank you any any points of um
anybody else indicating to speak
um we're on the debate on this uh
whoa it's a tricky one um
it does appear to me as a
patch council said a bit of land
grabbing there um
i'm just trying to think of a good
planning reason why
we shouldn't have it uh gosh
is it over development i mean it doesn't
give them much spaces this
house does it for garden to have another
house built there i mean when i looked
at the site i thought
gosh you're squeezing something in here
um
at the present mr chairman it i've seen
a little bit of
over development to me but i'll listen
listen to what the others have got to
say
thank you very much okay i think you
might have been the
um last speaker i don't think anybody
else is
indicated to speak yes please
okay is that change
is that your counselor harvard yes
um my view is that the
the officer has considered thoroughly
the question of
whether this constitutes over
development or not
and i am quite happy to go along with
her
conclusion that it does not um and i'm
quite happy that we should move to a
vote
thank you well we'll move on to the
onto the verb we've had a proposal and a
second to grab the application
all those in fiverr uh sorry i can have
to go back to
democratic services officer lisk will
you come in again
please thank you chairman councillor
crump
or councillor mills
or councillor fielding
for councillor fleming
for councillor harvey
chester harvey
oh thank you that's unanimous chairman
all right committee results to grant
application twenty
zero slash zero zero three six one slash
out
thank you and then move on to our next
one
and again with the small
interlude i like that word interlude
um
[Music]
are we all ready to go
president i am oh yes mr chairman
raring to go
correct mr chairman good good thank you
that
somebody is already asleep i think
right we all now move on to the next
item on the agenda which should be
19 class 0 3310
fur 11 byron war temple hardwick
and our presenting officer is erin
witherstone erin please
far away thank you chairman please may
check everyone can see the presentation
on the screen
i guess i can see it
happy yep great the application site
lies the west of temple herdwick village
within the physical confines of the
settlement
extent of the application site is
outlined in red it includes an
end of terrorist dwelling shown here
with its garden land amenity land to the
east
in this area here and extends over the
highway verge
as you can see here up to the road
the site lies directly to the north of
the mod base which is down
in this location here and adjacent to a
footway
which you can see just here which
connects byron walk to the south
the site has neighboring properties to
the west here
attached to properties and to the east
you can see just here
on the plan the site lies directly south
of shared parking areas which you can
see
approximately here on the plan planning
permission is sought for material change
of use of the existing amenity land
to garden land the direction of a
single-story extension to be used as a
garage
and the creation of a new vehicular
access to the highway
this slide shows existing and proposed
elevations
see the existing along the top and
proposed along the bottom
a single story lean to extension is
proposed just here
to the side of the property with a
garage door facing onto the road
materials are proposed to match the host
property
this slide shows the existing and
proposed floor plans you can see the
existing
on the left and the proposed on the
right proposed extension would follow
the same shape of the amenity land and
see going from
approximately 2.5 meters in width closer
to the road to 4 meters in width to the
rear of the extension
and be the full depth of the existing
host property
this slide shows a photograph of the
host building from the road
the works are part retrospective insofar
as the access has been created on the
site and the land is currently being
used as garden land enclosed by a fence
you can see just here
and the access to the front that's part
retrospective
the neighboring property is shown to the
left of the image with the front garden
you can see open here
and the footwear leading to the mod base
to the south
this light has a number of photographs
of the wider street scene close to the
application site just to give you a feel
for the character of the area
look at this image here this is the
application site just here the bottom
right
the number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet
it is recommended that planning
permission be refused for the reason set
out in the officer report
thank you right
thank you aaron we'll move on to our
first speaker uh which is
catch the hannah dale
that's the dale are you with us
remember you've been a committee sir so
uh
terrible times are you i don't know
whether you want to i don't know whether
you
want to go with the applicant is the
applicant speaking
uh yeah he is
i'm just german assistant malloy yeah
because that yeah
by the time he's had his his beer hannah
should be here i mean i can read out
hannah's speech but it would be better
coming from hannah david do you happy we
can do that
that's i've got no issues but uh david
ross
german i'm i'm happy for you to switch
the order of the speakers
brilliant um you um thank you ben
mr malloy oh you ha yeah thank you for
swapping the order no problem
so just to convert the presentation as
well so i'll bring that up on the
slideshow that's okay
is somebody muted because i can't hear
anything
i'm here
chairman would you prompt the uh
applicant to speak
please yeah mr malloy are you um
you've got three minutes we'll come here
yep happy to start now you've got three
minutes and we'll give you a warning
with 30 seconds to go
and please stand alone for any questions
okay
okay i'll start now um there have been
several points of concerns
raised by the planning department during
this application i've taken steps to
neutralize each of these concerns in
turn changing the size
design and adding the crossover to my
boundary
in order to appease the proposed
extension by reason of its design
position and size is considered
considered to have an adverse impact on
the open character experience within the
locality
of the site when considering the
requirements of policy cs
0.9 given there is no specific
issue stated it is hard to amend the
plans in order
to appease um in this instance i'm able
to demonstrate however that
there are several other properties in
the vicinity with similar extensions
i've produced photos of these and have
guided
and around to view the these examples in
person
the size and position of my proposed
extension is not dissimilar to these
other examples and the design in
sympathetic
to the look of the row of houses next to
it
um i have the support of the parish
council six sets of neighbours in the
immediate vicinity formal uh
confirmation
of no objection in additional to
crossover permission
granted by the residence company who own
the land
and the road adjacent to the site and i
i have verbal support from
my district councillor um as far as i'm
aware
there have been no objections anywhere
apart from the planning department
according to the parish council meeting
earlier this month
um yeah that's that's what i've got to
say
right any questions for the applicant
please
no any
no are we obviously we're looking at the
uh the slides which we haven't seen
properly yet so i'm
happy for
happy to see those okay perfect
all right cancel the fielding i can just
see your hand now
um just a quick question how many you're
gonna have one car
um parking area in the garage
is how many bedrooms do you have
i have a two-bedroom it's two-bedroom
house fair enough
thank you thank you very much yeah
and can i just remind or or counselors
it's
um i'm a man i do have trouble
multitasking
um if members can
indicate they want to speak in the chat
function it makes it a lot easier for me
because i can't see everybody's
picture i can only see cancer the field
at the moment
so i can't see if you're waving to me
or taking your glasses off or anything
else so
it would either could you say speak
please or use the chat function
um i do still good to see people um
you know i do along for the days of
elizabeth house where i can actually see
people and
move the order around um but
now we're doing the the new normal it is
very difficult so
um have i got somebody
indicating that
no all right
i can't see any questions unless the
officers can see anybody indicating
that mr malloy you are free to go but
stay with us
uh to listen to to the rest of the way
thank you for
being the moving around the order
thank you very much um we can now
move on to the parish council and
hopefully
councillor dale is with us now
catch the dale can you can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
um
is with us man hello
hello i can but i have you
on the phone and uh on the laptop as
well so i'm not sure
can we just ask you if you can mute your
laptop because there's a time delay
and that's going to distract from what
you've got to say
okay i've muted the laptop i'm i'm
waiting now
for something to happen when we
yep we can we can hear you now catch the
doubt yeah we were getting feedback and
i was saying something and it was coming
through about 10 seconds later
um are you okay to go ahead with your
presentation i am indeed i'm just
bringing it up i've
walked in the door a few minutes ago so
[Music]
yeah yeah we did we tried to move to
try to move you around so we could uh
cancel the gordon comey
was uh was on standby but buddy
i apologize for that it was a tricky
evening
let me just bring up
technology hey that's right you don't
have to tell me that cancer dale you
know i'm
i'm enjoying the battle every fortnight
with the planning committee system and
uh councillors and being unmuted and
lost broadband connection and
delays and things like that so i can
fully sympathize
i'm trying to put it out a bit so you
can have a little bit longer to get
ready so
i if anyone has the document i um
i'm about to read out then they can read
it out and i can take questions on it or
i can
find it shortly chairman i
i have um councillor dale's uh statement
here
[Music]
council has previously supported this
application
citing increased parking provision and
improved road safety
the section of road adjacent to eleven
by one walk is lined on the left with
private parking slots perpendicular to
the road
because there are fewer allocated
parking spaces than vehicles in this
area
there are frequently cars parked along
the entire length of the kerb on the
right
whilst there is a turning point in the
road the stretch outside 11 by 1 walk is
beyond this turning point
making this particular section difficult
to navigate in a vehicle
impossible to turn in without utilizing
a private parking space
and with limited visibility due to so
many cars parking kerbside
you've all seen the photos have been
submitted to demonstrate how tight the
parking is
this application will provide extra
parking potentially removing a car from
the curbside
by virtue of the crossover agreement in
place for the driveway it also provides
slightly increased visibility
because parking on the crossover is
prohibited
with regard to the requirement of policy
cs9 it is difficult to see justification
for refusal based on the open character
of the site
at least three similar extensions can be
seen from rows within temple hardwick
one of which is a similar brick built
lean to extension
and i understand that photographic yeah
so you've seen photographic evidence of
all of the different
extensions that exist on the site in
addition to these examples
it is also worth noting that a stone's
throw from the application site
across a section of open grassland there
is an unattractive garage block
whilst ugliness is personal and cannot
be measured
it is difficult to justify refusing
permission for a single extension
in keeping with the adjacent housing
when it is inside of a squat
unsightly garage block in need of
maintenance
i understand photos of the garage block
and its proximity of the application
site are also available to the committee
finally it is noted there are four
supportive neighbor comments in the
portal in respect to this application
there have been no neighbor objections
nor have there been any concerns or
objections raised in consultation
and the proposal is supported by the
parish council in summary berndacek
parish council would ask that the
committee find in favor of this
application
thank you thank you
for the joints effort from from uh
burton dussett thank you um right any
questions
for the parish council please
no any questions no um
could uh cancel out could you just go
back um just
about the the parking and and the access
um cancer gordon coming touched upon
that
um
could just just just reiterate that for
me please i didn't quite
hear that properly
which section was it you're looking for
it was the bit about the parking and the
access
and i know there's some pictures there
was um pictures from the applicant that
it was shown
the roads were were really
it is crowded crowded um as you drive
round on this section of road you pass
the turning point on your right
um and then you follow the road around
the corner and on the left there are
parking slots
allocated parking spots for residents
um there aren't enough because everybody
needs a car these days if you live in
the countryside
um so people also park on the curb on
the right
which makes it utterly impossible to
make any sort of movement
in that section of road unless you use
one of the parking bays
and there's no guarantee they'll be free
so you're left with the other option of
returning reversing all the way
back round so that's really tricky
there will be a slot available on the
road
assuming nobody blocks in the driveway
which is
the point that i was trying to make here
so it will give a little bit more
flexibility
in the road because the driveway will be
in constant use
brilliant thank you for that
it provides a passing spot or a crossing
spot as well on the on the left beyond
the parking
there is a section of open grassland
which if there's kids from the houses
they have to cross the road to get to
now at the minute there isn't always a
gap
on the curb whereas again with the
driveway there will be a gap so it does
increase visibility a little bit
yeah no no that's really clear no that's
thank you i'm
i'm glad i asked the question and we
gave you the opportunity to
expand your question a bit answer as
well so
all right all right photo here shows the
grassland opposite
on the other side of the parking yep
brilliant thank you very much any
any other questions to the parish
councillors
no can't see anything again with
wonderful technology um thank you very
much you're free to go but stay with us
for
for the debate um thank you
right our next speaker is cancer cattle
cancer cattle
thank you mr chairman sorry the unmuting
was taking a bit of time
um right um this
uh settlement uh was built as the
married quarters to um the um
royal logistics corps camp next
immediately adjacent to the site
uh unlike a lot of ministry of defense
um
married quarters it's not a error of
great beauty
but what is quite clear is there are
significant areas of open space
which that previous slide demonstrated
um throughout throughout the development
one thing um that clearly marks it out
when you go around the site or around
the
settlement is the significant
um shortage of car parking spaces
uh there are there are as the slide in
front of your shows
there are car parks laid out throughout
the site
but if you look at the number of housing
units um
it is in the the car parking provided
when the
site was built in where it was actually
twice before i was born
they are no longer adequate for uh the
current need
of the existing residents of this
village
um so we do have a car parking problem
where the officer is coming from
and um i understand why she has written
what she has written
um is that this is uh
like a lot of buildings uh like a lot of
mod sites
they are fairly standard in form um
and therefore the proposed changes
are different to that form
but as has been pointed out there are a
number of other
uh similar type of um
uh developments have been put onto other
houses in the area
and therefore i think it is a very
personal issue that needs to be
addressed
as to whether the um change
in built form of this property is
sufficient um
to overall benefit in in parking
provision across the whole estate
and also in comparison whether there's
one
small addition to this property given
however many properties there are and
you can see again in the error of a
photograph
um given about the considerable number
of bodies there are there
um whether it is going to be materially
detrimental to the estate and such
um so it it is up to members on this one
to to really consider whether the
addition of
this lean to which is is definitely
considerably smaller than the house it's
being appended to
um does have a material impact on
um design distinctiveness under cs9
um or whether whilst clearly does have
an impact
that impact is overruled by the
significant benefits
to the community as a whole as clearly
set out by councillor dale
um albeit in her alter ego
of um councillor gordon [ __ ] uh
anyone's got questions i'm delighted to
answer them
right any questions for cancer cattle
[Music]
come on it's a chance to get your own
back on counselor kettle for all the
awkward questions he's asked you in the
past
i object to that comment mr chairman i
tried to be objective
at all stages sorry challenging
questions from councillor kettle in the
past
thank you mr travis
um just with using your local knowledge
council kettle
um i'll get the impression from uh
the paris council that there is quite
strong support for this
uh application um
what what you mentioned that you've had
some feedback on it as well could you
just
lose the data a little bit more with
that please well now i attended the last
parish council meeting and
the parish council clearly indicated
support for its application of that
meeting
um and uh as far as i'm aware there have
been no letters of rejection received
from local residents
um so um
you know the people are aware of it uh
if there was a significant concern about
it
um i think that that would have raised
that issue would have been raised by
other residents um
this is not a village with many listed
properties in fact i can almost
guarantee um this weather through my
sales wise but i don't think there are
any listed
mr buildings anywhere in the vicinity of
this
she's uh shaking her head and i assume
in agreement
um it's it
temple holding is what it is it is not
it is not a settlement of
uh and your apologies to today you did
that
council dale um it's not an
area of enormous beauty um so the
question is
is the impact of this small edition
going to be
sufficient to um
object this application on cs9 terms
um this weatherstring does stay quite
clearly within
in terms of cs20 this application um
meets those guidelines um and um
you know so it does really go to
balances having seen the picture having
seen the design
does the committee think i think my
question
give you a little bit of lead way so i
think you've answered the question
any more questions for the ward number
no thank you right then we'll now
move on to the debate technical
questions
excuse me chairman could you see my note
please i
did is it three hours liz or three and a
half
it's three hours chairman
right it doesn't time fly i'll come back
to you with two seconds cancel harvey
um right we need to vote as the
meeting's gone on
it's time flowing so quickly we've been
here three hours now
um we need to vote that uh we are
prepared to carry on with the meeting
i propose that we do uh i need a second
day for that please
seconded super
thank you uh
on this side here anything to the
country i
will take that as
carried carried
yep right we'll
know cancer harvey sorry technical
question
um can i take you to page 45
paragraph four
in which the officer reports that this
garage does not meet the minimum space
requirements i wonder if
the officer could tell us um
the duck what's involved here is it is
it the width of the opening
uh is it the volume of the of the
construction or whatever
i'm trying to get at how far short of
the required standard
is this proposition
yes so in terms of the parking standards
we do have some in our svd part
oh which is parking and travel and the
size of the spaces really relates to
what's either side so in this case where
the boundary features to both sides
we'd be looking at three meters by five
meters
and at the moment at the entrance of the
the garage it's two and a half meters
in width across um so whilst they might
have the length
it's you might might find you can fit a
small car in there but our parking
standards are based on vehicles so you
might find that a larger vehicle
wouldn't fit
so in this case officers have determined
that it would have a neutral impact on
parking
because of the minimum space standards
haven't been met in this case
so just to just interpret play that back
and interpret it
what you're saying is that there are
cars which won't fit in this garage
as proposed and therefore it won't make
any difference to the parking
facilities in the area generally
that's correct so we're saying it's
having a neutral impact on the parking
um availability in the area just because
internally it doesn't meet our minimum
separation the minimum
base standards for parking sizes where
you've got boundary features on either
side
and to state the the obvious while
somebody may own a car which is small
enough to go in at the moment
a future uh occupant of the property may
have a car which won't
that's correct so we've got to look at
the the planning use so it's the use of
the
property as a dwelling and that is a
garage it might be that it's used as a
garage for other purposes but for
parking purposes
it may not fit a larger vehicle if a new
family was to move into the property for
example
so to be facetious this garage might be
being used as a study
so we're considering this as an
extension to the property yes
and so whilst there's vehicular access
and a new garage door
if if it was to be built out it could be
used as part of the dwelling house it's
not limited just to a garage
thank you thank you
right
[Music]
we'll now move on to the divide
of of my decision this that there was no
dissent for us
to carry on uh so i've
taken it and have it recorded that it
was a unanimous decision
to to carry on um save the roll call
right move on to the debate who wants to
start on this one
i'm quite happy to start catch the
harvey then cancel the mills please
i have a problem with this um i can see
merits on both sides
um my my real concern
is that on the one hand i can see the
the detriment to the
to the visual immunity of allowing this
on the other hand
if there are precedents already set on
three occasions
i think was mentioned in one of the
speeches one of the statements
that uh similar sort of developments
have been
permitted i presume granted permission
by a planning committee in the past
um i'm i'm i'm
i'm struggling uh between the two should
i go
with consistency because it's been
allowed before
or on and why should we penalize this
particular applicant
on the other hand if the garage won't
necessarily won't be guaranteed to serve
its purpose
because it doesn't meet the required
standard in terms of size
that mitigates against it so i am i'll
be interested in
other members views
thank you question harvey councillor
mills yes thanks mr chairman yes like
just like trevor i've been bouncing
backwards
and forwards on this one um
my immediate thoughts were to go go
against the officer's recommendation
then
listen to the officer about the size of
the garage
when it fit a car in there oh gosh it's
a difficult one isn't it
um my thoughts
are
my thoughts are at the moment i could
change my mind though uh
to go with the officer's recommendation
i'll listen to what others have to say
on this one but
it's a tricky one it really is i thought
i thought it's pretty easy
but it ain't thank you mr chairman
with all this bouncing backwards and
forwards catch the mills are you sure
you're not on a trampoline rather than
on a chair
it feels like that at the moment mr
chairman i have to say
thank you mr jeffries would you want to
come in on
uh for a moment please yes please thank
you chair um i
i know it's particularly early for me to
interject but i
i think that it needs bringing to
members attention that um
the matter before members is not simply
the erection of a garage
members also need to consider that this
is an area of um
land which may be owned by the applicant
but which has not
formally been garden land this is
amenity land
so we're also looking at the change of
use i just wanted to make sure that
members
brought that into their considerations
before reaching conclusions
thank you david cancer fleming
yeah well i'm just uh listening to what
david said there
um it said it's not garden land well if
it was garden land it wouldn't have a
garage built on top of it either i don't
suppose
and the problem is in an earlier
reference tonight we were reminded
that there are rules to be adhered to
officers stick to those rules
and we shouldn't be making them
arbitrary so i'm a bit like
you know i don't see any great harm in
this thing but
where do we go as far as you know
sticking to the rules
so from that perspective i'm not sure
which way to go whether
i feel as though i should be banned by
the rules that the officers set
in which case there's really no no need
for a planning
decision because the officers can then
make that decision but at the same time
we're here to uh to to try and get a
solution that
that fits both the council's
requirements but also the applicant's
requirements so again i'm not sure which
way i'll go with it but i will bear that
uh the officers uh you know that
they set the they read the rules and
send to sell them to us
so that's what the way i'm thinking at
the moment
thank you for that cancer flaming counts
the hancher seraphin
please hey thank you chair
um can i ask the case officer
aaron the exact width at the front of
the garage
yes it's approximately 2.5 meters at the
the width at the front
and moving back to four meters towards
the rear of the property
yeah so a standard garage door is seven
foot in old measurements
so we got six foot six plus five hundred
yeah i understand that being being very
tight
would it would it be any benefit if they
move the front of the garage slightly
back
to increase the width of it
we have to consider the application
before us
we're looking at it as it's submitted
and we're looking at also the internal
space so if you're opening car doors on
both sides
that's why the minimum stay space
standards make reference to boundary
treatments on both sides of this space
okay thank you cast the failing
that's the feeling
sorry my language is going to get
muted your language will be muted if
it's
not appropriate
right there you go um
just the comment is that you don't
normally open your car doors when you're
just going into the garage
if there's a width further back into the
garage
then um i can't see a problem
it's rather like trying to king
solomon's problem with the
ownership of the you know which way to
go um
i think everyone's sort of wanting to
abstain from the sound of things
um i don't know i have i have no answer
to it
one side of me says yes go ahead and
give them the permission
but uh there we go i i don't know the
answer
thanks i'll just come in on this one
um the whole point of the planning
application is to decide on
the policies and consider
whether right the
it's whether it will cause any harm to
the open character
and the street scene so in your opinion
it will or it won't and
whether the change of use and
development of an area
is considered to be fully justified or
not
justified or offer significant benefits
or don't offer significant benefit
so we've got a choice we've got the
decision
it's based on you know we've got the
policies but it's
members opinion and views as well
so it's it will either harm or it won't
harm
and it's either justified
or not justified um because it will
offer significant benefits to the local
area required by policy
so it's a question that um the planning
balance
to go for or against and
[Music]
whether it will cause any harm and
whether it's justified
um etc so that's that's the thing so
i'll lock on it
there's always two sides in the argument
and this is
where we should be coming from on this
uh
catch the field in you indicated again
this thing to unmute
there we go um going on what you've said
and bearing in mind your comments we are
getting the traffic off the road we're
getting a car off the road
it doesn't seem to affect the street
scene because that's all
similar i'm prepared to propose that we
go against the officers and
um and grant
and so have we
uh so you're basically saying
um
[Music]
so you're basically saying the extension
etc
is not considered to harm the open
character
correct and you're saying that the
change of use and development of the
area
is considered to be fully justified
because of
the parking issue and
was it potentially the road
crossing north or spice or something
like that yeah yeah along the lines that
you you were referring to
i'm happy to go along with it so i don't
want to put
words in anybody's mouth but if we're
having a reason
we've got to go with the policy if you
know what i mean
we've got a policy so
right i think getting traffic off the
road is important
um you've got to make look after the
street scene
um so therefore you want to keep it free
of
um people being able to walk along the
footpaths so
access um by the community
um i know it's not any it's
as counselor kettle said the
um area is not listed or have a
um any distinction but you know it is
home to people and
they need to have the facilities
that this will give so um
it's it's a very very difficult one
right thank you a second for that
proposal
catch the mills have you indicated sorry
to speak not necessarily second the
proposal
yes it it's um i'm not sure i can ask
you this
uh stage of the debate about conditions
and can we put
a condition it could only be used for a
garage or not are we not allowed to do
that
because i'm not too sure about it's the
with the darn thing isn't it
it's david you are able to yeah yeah i'm
happy to help in that respect
if members are minded to approve the
application of course
we would seek a number of conditions um
that could include a condition um which
required that no
business be operated from the garage and
the garage be
only used ancillary to the enjoyment of
the dwelling house
um it's it's not ordinarily done to
impose a condition that it be used
solely for the housing of a motor
vehicle these days i
think that there's an acceptance that
people use their garages in different
ways
so um although a condition can be
imposed
it's it's often not reasonable to to
insist it's only for a car yeah yes uh
yes
cancer catch the hobby uh can i ask a
question of the officer please
can the officer tell us whether anything
that has been mentioned in the debate
so far has not been considered by her
or her colleagues and would she based
upon what she's heard this evening
would she change her recommendation
in terms of the officer assessment we've
taken into account all the material
considerations
um and that's how it's been put in the
office of reports we've taken everything
into account
um and we've weighed up and given weight
to the the elements
um as sat out in the office report and
we have concerns about the visual impact
of
the development on the character of the
area given uniform street scene and the
relationship of the extension with the
footwear in the gardens
which lie across the the footwear to the
site
so that's the of the recommendation
we've put forward in terms of parking
and we've given that we've said it's
neutral in terms of parking
given the minimum space down as we have
in the the svd so that's how we've come
to that conclusion
so i take that as a no
so in terms of your recommendation that
that's been finalized and put forward
taking into account all the
considerations so that's how officers
have weighed it up
and that's a recommendation that's been
put forward today
and i think to prefer to the officers
council harvey um
in the previous uh some of the previous
applications where
in particular we were going against
policy
um officers have come in and given
details of the policy
this one is more of a more of a judgment
decision
on the planet merits of um
the harm etcetera um so i think
the the officer's position is fair and
neutral
and um so yeah i'm happy with their
responses sir
right anybody else so
we've had a proposal to grant the
application
for the the reasons that cancer fielding
indicated
have we a seconder for that proposal
yes i'll second that catch that
handshake
yep chairman officers suggest a number
of conditions
david please i think if members were
minded to approve this application
we'd look for a condition um development
begun within three years
um did it accord with plans details of
materials be provided
the hard standings be made permeable
that water butts are provided
and that an electric vehicle charging
point be provided within the scheme
in some location erin can i call on you
see if there's anything i missed
going to suggest is boundary treatments
around the garden because the extension
is set in from
the edge of the garden area that's
proposed so if they're looking to put
any boundary treatment along adjacent to
the footway
it'd be for those details to be
submitted and approved
very well chair that's what your
officers would recommend
can i can i agree with with that the
the hedge and the fence line should be
such a height and a
position that it doesn't materially
damage the um
environment so i think counts of the
field has just indicated he's happy with
those conditions
thank you thank you all right we'll
go to the vote on the proposal
to grant the application
um this can i come back to you please
yes thank you chairman councillor crump
for
councillor mills benefits
grant the application thank you
councillor fielding
to to grant the application counselor
fleming
for councillor harvey
against councillor henshaw seraphin
uh for the application chairman that's
five votes four and one against
committee resolves to grant application
nineteen slash
zero three three one oh slash ful
thank you and again smaller interlude
when we call for our next application
thank you
so
good
right are we all here
um i'm here
right um we need to vote
um it's been told that teams
kicks us out after four hours now um
we've got two applications to get to get
through
um and
i'm pretty certain that you know we
wouldn't get both of them done in the
33 minutes we got left should we give it
a go
mr chairman um i'm happy
to go through one of them or try to get
through one of them um
with the proviso that the ward member
and the town council of speaking are
happy
that we might have to adjourn before
it's finished
so um we will do our best to get this
one finished
and as long as they're happy or would
they rather we adjourned
before they started chair i think it
would make
more sense to adjourn before we got
started
i think it's never ideal to have to
adjourn halfway through a meeting
and also if we adjourn before this next
item gets started it can then go to
either planning a or b
you know the next available slot which
would be um
better i think for the uh for the
applicant because they'll want this to
get to get on
as soon as possible i think it's very
unlikely you'd get this finished
um by 10 o'clock which is the time that
the teams will kick us out of the
meeting
i'm willing to be guided by the rest of
the committee
could we not try the one of them
mr chairman let's crack on through it
could i just say one more thing before
you decide whether you're going to
continue or not
you won't get a choice what will happen
is the live meeting will simply
end so you won't be able to then take a
decision to adjourn well somebody could
be halfway through speaking and it will
just cut out the live recording
we're wasting time should we just go for
it we'll go for it
okay uh
what's left which one looks less
complicated
we'll do the next one in order all right
then okay
right then victoria
thank you chair i'll just share my
screen now
um can you confirm that you can all see
that
yep happy yes i can see
i'll make a start so the application
site flies within a residential area to
the west of southern
the site occupies a corner position to
the south of the welsh road west
and to the west of st james's road this
plan shows the application site outlined
in red
the proposal is seeking to add multiple
additions including a two-story side
extension
single-story rear extension detached
garage and a new vehicle access
this slide shows the existing plans the
single story lean 2
shown here will be demolished to make
way for the new two-story side extension
in terms of proposed development the
north elevation shows the proposed
extension to the left-hand side
the side side extension will be set down
and set back from the main house
the front entrance door would also be
moved approximately 2.5 meters to the
left
as shown here the single-story
re-extension
and two-story extension would have a
length of approximately
3.85 meters when measured from the
existing rear wall
however the single-story re-extension
would only extend to three meters
closest to the neighbor at the west here
the development would incorporate
concrete roof tiles and facing brickwork
to match the existing materials
the floor plans show how the proposal
would create additional living space at
ground floor level
and create further two bedrooms at first
floor
overall inc internal reconfiguration of
the main house would
turn
you can also see that there will be an
associated hard standing area for three
vehicles where the three meets
is that better can you still hear me
that's better please proceed yes okay
perfect
sorry about that um
so you can see here where three meter
wide
porous gravel driveway would lead to the
garage at the rear here
so this slide shows photos of the front
elevation and also gives you an idea of
the road layout where the drop curb
would be
as indicated by the red arrow the site
evidently occupies a generous corner
plot
this slide shows the rear of the site
from st james is close and the red arrow
indicates the location of the proposed
garage here taking into account the
site's location
technical consultation responses scale
and design of the extensions
proposal is not considered to cause harm
to the character and appearance of the
streetscape
or to highway safety it is recommended
that this application should be approved
subject to conditions
for the reasons set out in the officers
report
in terms of updates there has been a
correction for the date of the parish's
response on the 14th of april
the parish also confirmed that they
maintain this objection as outlined in
the update
sheet i would also like to make you
aware that a committee
site visit was made this morning which
was attended by the chair and other
members
thank you thank you yep yes at james's
road that was
not sent changed was crescent it just a
slight update that victoria but
no not a problem let's move on to our
first speaker which is councillor mike
brooks please
from southern town council council
brooks far away when you're ready please
mr chairman yes i'm here uh
the town council objects to this
application regarding the proposed
access point
when the application was first presented
two access points were proposed one on
walsh road west
and the other on st james road the
property is in a corner plot which
borders both roads as you can see
our original objection was twofold
concerned over the access point
proposed onto welsh road west directly
opposite another junction without
changes to the road layout
and that two access points potentially
gave the opportunity for the plot to be
subdivided which we believe
would have constituted over development
in this area
whilst we appreciate that highways have
removed their original objection
on the two access ways following the
redrafted plans removing one of them
the town council believes that the wrong
access has been dropped
washroad west is a major highway leading
east from the town centre that supports
the local communities
and is the only road enabling coaches to
transport pupils to south and college in
both directions
recently it's also been the main route
for hs2 construction traffic
during peak hours particularly in
inclement weather it's often gridlocked
and best avoided if possible the council
has been looking at ways to reduce
traffic flow and provide safer walking
routes for pupils for many years
last year finally managing to get a
pedestrian crossing installed adjacent
to the primary school
after a long campaign in the town
council's view
an access onto james road with much
lower levels of traffic
is a safer and more sustainable solution
providing a direct route to the high
street bypassing the problematic
washroom west and coventry road junction
there is ample space to the rear of the
site where the proposed double garaging
is situated
to provide for the additional parking
spaces and allow movement of vehicles
so they can approach james road in a
forward gear
finally from the design aspect this
access would alleviate the need for this
snaking track
within the plot from front to rear which
is shown in the current proposed
layout version thank you thank you
thanks to the brooks any questions for
the town council
um yet very brief accounts to box if
obviously you're now the area while has
been county council ward member for that
one and i know the person who actually
got the
pedestrian crossing in good chap i
believe
um could you just again
emphasize to the committee what your
thoughts
about the parking particularly around
school time and
in that area obviously there's several
lines etc there so yeah just just your
just updated the committee for those who
weren't able to attend the site visit
today
yeah certainly um i'm unfortunate or
sometimes unfortunate enough to
live off a side road of uh welsh road
west
uh and i've been caught out on numerous
occasions uh during peak school hours on
this one
um having had to wait anything like up
to about 20 minutes to get from
whereabouts the uh the leisure center is
which is just past the entrance to the
to the college
um to get to uh commentary road
um so now after learning um
from several mistakes i i take the back
routes
uh to come out onto market hill um
first thing in the morning what you'll
see is uh
says especially if it's raining or
there's all these severe weather
conditions
you'll get uh parents dropping their
their pupils off either at
the entrance to the college or they'll
just park along
either side of the road drop them off
and then do u-turns and all sorts of
weird things
you've also got coaches coming in from
both ends
and at the same time the leisure center
is usually open so you've got people
coming to
to get a fit or try and get fit there as
well
and when i say gridlocked i really do
mean gridlocked
it can can block up quite a large number
of roads
but strangely enough it doesn't block
ups and james road
and i think the reason for that is that
um people trying to
get on to access to to welsh road west
to get to
coventry road uh they'll wait sort of
five or ten minutes in a queue
and then your brain kind of takes over
it kind of says to yourself well i'm
making progress so i'm going to see it
right through to the end
and i'll stick where i am even though
you may have
an ideal opportunity or an option to go
down to
st james's road and cut all of that out
it's a strange quirk of mankind i
suppose
but it does get extremely busy there
so i mean i suppose our argument on this
one is
is twofold really um which is the safest
uh access on to a major highway
and which one provides the best options
um now if the welsh road west
access stays as it is then
uh during peak school as if uh if the
occupants um sorry
the applicant wants to uh to get access
on to welsh road
he would have to cross a traffic flow
having waited to get
a space to get into it and then either
way the 10 minutes to get on to
uh to the coventry road or if he felt so
inclined then kind of double back on
himself
by crossing the traffic flow again to
come down james's road
having the alternative access point from
james road in the first place would we
think
uh from local knowledge give him um
alternative options
depending on the traffic conditions at
the time
so that's our that's our take on local
knowledge
thank you councillor brooks i don't
think anybody else is dedicated to
to speak
no the turtle was scratching his head
then i thought he was waving no
right uh right that's the quirks of this
wonderful system
thank you councillor brooks now move on
to our speaker next speaker which is
ward member
councillor bromwich tony can you come in
you've got five minutes please
yeah good evening everybody right i have
a few objections on this
first of all i think it is substantial
over development to the side
as mentioned in my comments this
actually
pretty much doubles the size of the
property and i think it's completely out
of context
with the whole of the street i've had
great reservations as well about the
road access for
many of the reasons councilor brooks
mentioned previously
i also have reservations about the
potential james's road
access which was one of my original
objectives before that was removed
because i actually disagree with council
books because sometimes this road
is equally as busy and when it gets down
to market hill end
having sat there myself for a good ten
minutes to try and get through the
traffic on a narrow road
both access points onto the main road
are very bad
overall i think that when you
those who increase it to the sites
they've got a very good context on the
actual size of this development which i
don't think the plans give
and it is basically almost putting
a no another property on the side here
and because of that i think this is way
way over the top
by the time you put a double garage at
the back on top of that
there a substantial proportion of this
land is going to end up being developed
and i do not think it's an appropriate
thing to actually do
i don't think it's in context with
anywhere within the actual
area i don't think that when you look at
it there is an actual genuine
need when you look at their plans to
actually have such a huge
proportion of this land developed other
than you would be looking on the longer
term of subdivide that's mentioned by
councillor brooks
that could be the only possible reason
for such a huge development
on that and i'm happy to take any
questions
about the sizing and that because it is
literally
again putting a substantial development
on the side
and for those reasons i don't think this
application should be accepted
thank you council bromwich uh any
questions to
the ward member
any questions um
i'm going to tell you a good comment
really i'll share your concerns
about the road safety issues um
either entrance is not brilliant dumbed
if you do dumbed if you don't
um i think i'd just about slightly
support
the welsh road west one but
very limited and i agree with the 10
council
councillor's assertion that the person
who lives there will have difficulty
getting in and out
at peak time um but
you know that obviously that the
applicant would have known about that
when
they bought the property um certainly
um but i'm just slightly you know i i'm
saying i'm sure you're concerned
um i know um
the traffic just got significantly built
up there
um but yeah it is quite a difficult one
um
any any other comments whilst i've been
waffling any for the ward number
catch the cattle
yeah mr the um well back to the same
issue we had on the first application
tonight some three and a half hours ago
um where we are discussing
highways um and on page 51
on the consultations we have no
morris county council highways um as you
know i don't live far from
uh southam and i'm fully fully aware
of the um um congestion you can get on
welsh road west
um but i do think as a committee
we have a problem here and i would
differentiate from the other application
that there was other evidence i think on
this one
we have no other evidence from county
other than
they have no objection to this i
completely see your point
um and you're pulling out of the drives
going uphill with the junction meeting
opposite you
on the road which is when i arrived at
10 o'clock
meeting um i was following a fairly
significant htv
um but i'm not quite sure that is a
um a reason that we can use to
um to object in this case um
i appreciate it is a significant
additional development and i understand
council bloomberg's concerns on that um
but it is quite a big plot
um and um um
i haven't i'm not so concerned about the
size issue
it's really this highways issue we've
got
from highways
right is any any further questions for
council bromwich
right we'll move on to technical
questions any points
for the officer
um yeah one one mr chairman
far away at cancer castle um council
bombage
mentioned um the significant um
additional area of built form what is
are there any issues about suds or
drainage or anything else like that
where this additional water can be
captured to ensure that we don't get
any significant runoff or any additional
runoff
victoria can you hear us yes
no velocity it's going quiet
chair i can perhaps help a little bit um
the application proposal lies within
flood zone one the area of lowest risk
of
um floods so from that point of view um
it's a sort of preferred location for
development less at risk
of uh flooding and drainage concerns
um there isn't at the current time
a condition imposed or or recommended
however if members thought it was
necessary
as part of the approval a permeable
finish to the surface could be requested
and details of any drainage associated
with that
would be received by the planning
authority as part of that condition
thank you mr jefferies jeffrey and any
other questions
any technical questions
no we'll
move on to the debate who do you want to
start on this one
i can't see any comments at the moment
uh
yeah customers
thanks mr chairman i mean this is um
quite a big plot
i think it could uh
take the extension i'm a little bit
concerned about the
the rear uh of the property that that uh
single story how it impinges on next
door um
a little bit concerned about that i'm
not so worried about the um
drop curve going on to well road
because you know lots of other um
properties go onto that road um
i'm i'm referring towards the officer's
recommendation but um
i could be persuaded i'm just a bit
concerned about this
single story extension the back how that
impinges on the uh
neighbor but um i'll just listen to what
other people are saying mr chairman
i won't be too long now cancer cattle
i can't hear you chris i'm coming from
very much where council mills is in fact
he probably said what i was going to say
okay it's the harvey um
yes i presume that the applicant knows
well
what the problems are uh in uh
in that road uh access-wise and so on uh
i think this will only add
marginally to whatever the existing
problem might be
i think broadly put the uh the plot is a
large one and can take up
an extension of this size and if the
officer has made a clear recommendation
i'm happy to go with it and if necessary
i'd be quite happy to
propose uh that we moved to the vote as
soon as possible
thank you have we got a second
for that
catch the fielding are you second in are
you waving
i'm not waving um i i will second it
okay i'll i'll just let you know mike
my concerns obviously on early area well
i did goes to school at the the college
just over the road and i can attest to
the parking difficulties etc and
opposite
um springs crosston when it was
accessed as well um we are slightly
hamstrung
with the uh lack of objection from the
highways authority
and i know the st james road access will
be
removed under the permitted development
access rights are going to be removed
as part of the application
um i certainly you know i must admit
i don't like this application it is a
very big plot um
and i think it you know the even though
the application is sizable
um i think there is the sufficient
property space there for it to happen i
don't like the single extra store
extension
at the back um and i'm also concerned
about
the the materials and the effect of the
drive that
runs down parallel with james's road
um and how in keeping that would be and
definitely concerned about materials and
without permeable etc um
so yeah i don't particularly like that
and
the other thing that we would not really
discuss and again
um is the hard and soft landscaping
um i'm again concerned about the safety
density james's road
those who attended the site visit saw
there were several posts
that had been put up that were suitable
for
accessing or putting hanging fences onto
that we're going to be about six foot
tall and again that's totally
unacceptable now to keep and so
if we were going to approve this one um
i would seek some conditions about
fencing and and
landscaping in particular um to ensure
it's not it still remains in keeping
with the street scene and landscaping
and also from a visibility
and road safety point of view so that's
where i am on this one
um so should we
any other people want to to speak on
this one
no no we've had a proposal
um could we just clarify which
additional conditions if any
um counselor harvey wants to include in
its proposal
i'm quite happy to leave that to the
offices thank you
sorry councillor harvey it's it's your
proposal um
councillor crump has raised a number of
conditions which
i think if he uh if it were to be
approved he would like to see
added um it's whether you would wish to
amend your proposal um to approve it in
accordance with the officer's
recommendation
subject to those conditions that
councillor crump mentioned
or not in particular the permeable
membrane
uh sorry the the permeable surfaces for
any hard surfacing
um and any details of any boundary
treatment
uh to be submitted to the local planning
authority
just need your confirmation on that
please confirmed
thank you
right um we're going to
[Music]
go to the vote on this one
to to grant the application in line with
the cancer
harvest proposal which was seconded by
cancer
building
thank you chairman councillor crump hi
again
[Applause]
councillor mills against
councillor fielding
could you say that again sorry for
granting
against councillor kettle fought
german that's one two three votes for
and four votes against
and the proposal falls
so we need a proposal
to refuse the diffusely
that's right and you need to clarify
reasons as well whoever proposes refusal
don't join me to go
um yes mr chairman um
can we say design i mean i'm against
this extension at the back so can i say
design i mean is that and and um
the effect on the street scene yes
can i do that or not counselor mills i
think
from the debate i can perhaps sum up a
few words
yeah please members considered the um
development was
excessively large in respect to the host
building but it wasn't sympathetic
to the street scene um
the the the design was perhaps contrived
in terms of the
access which wound its way across the
site and that there would be
um the potential for further harm from
boundary treatments
um as well
are you happy with that cancer nails
that sounds good to me mr chairman
i'll confirm the details of that reason
with the chair
following the committee yeah thanks
david
uh we're looking for a seconder on that
one
um okay i'll second that one then
so we we go to the vote uh
all those in favor of refusing uh the
application
as per catch the mills is proposal
thank you chairman councillor crump for
councillor mills fielding
against councillor fleming
for councillor harvey against
councillor henshaw seraphin
[Music]
four votes for two against
and one abstention
committee resolves to refuse
application 19-0-3-1-9
f-u-l and i think we need to
close the meeting there we've got very
few minutes left
many apologies to the next application
which is the wells born one i do
apologize for this
and again i think mr cancer jeffrey
sorry david i'll
insult you yeah by calling you a cancer
um
i think we need to vote and send it
first of all send our apologies
to uh the parish council and second we
need to vote
to do further application um i'm
proposing that we do that now
i need a seconder on that yeah
second so uh all those in favor
of chairman can we just do a roll call
please yes sorry
liz councillor crump for
councillor mills or councillor fielding
or councillor fleming for
councillor harvey for councillor hensha
serafin
and councillor cattle paul
that's unanimous chairman thank you
thank you committee resolves to
defer the next application and we have
no urgent business i believe
none chairman i'll declare this meeting
closed well i hope your teacher's
impressed
you